voilà je vous propose de commencer notre
commission les derniers commissaires
vont très certainement nous rejoindre
donc bonjour à à toutes et à tous madame
le Maire de mouse monsieur le maire de
Saint-Denis très heureux de vous
accueillir dans cette enceinte de la
commission des affaires économiques mes
chers collègues donc nous accueillons
aujourd'hui Madame Michelle Lutz maire
de mulouse et Monsieur Mathieu anotin
maire de Saint-Denis tous les deux qui
sont auteurs d'un rapport que vous venez
qui vient de vous être distribué par la
mairie de Saint-Denis ou en tout cas qui
a été réalisé donc au niveau des
services de la mairie de Saint-Denis euh
qui a été remis au ministre le 23
octobre dernier au ministre du Logement
et qui porte sur les outils d'habitat et
d'urbanisme à créé ou à améliorer pour
renforcer la lutte contre l'habitat
digne et le traitement des copropriétés
dégradées donc avant de vous laisser la
parole madame le Maire et Monsieur le
Maire pour présenter bien sûr vos
travaux je voudrais au préalable en
rappeler le cadre Lana estime qu'il y
aurait 9 millions de logements dans les
copropriétés fragilisées vous-même
évaluez le nombre de logements indiges à
400000 et à 1 million celui de leurs
habitants c'est dire l'importance du
sujet et des mesures aussi bien
préventives que correctives et curatives
à prendre depuis le lancement du Plan
initiative copropriété et le vote de la
loi élan en 2018 beaucoup a été fait le
plan initiative copropriété prévoit 3
milliards d'investissements sur 10 ans
pour traiter 1117 copropriétés
identifiés dont 20 % environ sur 17
sites en suivi national de son côté la
loi hélan a permis de réformer les
polices vous s'en souviendraz en tout
cas pour ceux qui étaient déjà membres
de la commission des affaires
économiques puisque nous avions à
l'époque et au moment de du drame de la
rue d'auubagne euh décidé ici même dans
la commission des affaires économiques
de faire un rapport pour améliorer la
lutte contre l'habitat indigne ou
dangereux puisque c'est notre collègue
euh c'est de Marseille à l'époque Bruno
Gill qui avait déposé une proposition de
loi suite justement au drame de la rue
d'auagne donc nous avions fait ce
rapport que je vous remets
officiellement Madame et Monsieur le
Maire même si bien conscience qui
commence un petit peu à dater que
certainement il ne traite pas tout
autant le spectre des des sujets que
vous avez V même plus traiter mais voilà
ce qu'on avait déjà réalisé conscient
que c'était des sujets au combien
important à l'échelle de tout le
territoire national et donc cela s'est
traduit concrètement par une
augmentation de 30 % du nombre d'arrêtés
d'insalubrité 3600 en 2022 et une
centaines de condamnations par an de
marchands de sommeil dans nos
territoires nous savons tous que le
renouvellement de certains quartiers
bute sur le problème de l'habitat privé
dégradé dans lequel il est beaucoup plus
difficile d'intervenir parce que sa
propriété est émiéée qu'il n'existe pas
les organe de gestion et de décision
idouine et que le droit de la propriété
ou de la copropriété peut servir de
paravant à des marchands de sommeil à
des trafiquants et à des gestionnaires
verreux c'est donc dans ce contexte
qu'Olivier clin ancien ministre du
Logement et surtout maire de clichis
sous-bois vous avez demandé à l'un et à
l'autre à l'une et à l'autre de
réfléchir aux nouveaux outils à
mobiliser pour sortir des impas pass ou
des blocages actuels traiter une
copropriété peut prendre une vingtaine
d'années
parallèlement le Gouvernement a préparé
un projet de loi qu'il a d'ailleurs
tenté de faire passer par ordonnance
cette été et donc ça avait suscité un
émoi ici au Sénat puisque c'était dans
le cadre du projet de loi sur la
reconstruction en urgence des bâtiments
et des édifices qui avaient été
endommagés ou détruits suite aux émeutes
de l'été dernier et il y avait donc ce
fameux article 4 sur lequel ici nous
avions dit au gouvernement on ne votera
pas ce projet de loi si cet article 4
est maintenu dans ce véhicule législatif
parce que nous considérions que
justement traiter la question de
l'habitat indiges et des copropriétés
dégradées était un sujet bien trop
important et beaucoup trop lourd à
traiter pour être mis dans un projet de
loi qui était un projet de loi d'urgence
et donc le gouvernement en a pris acte
et a retiré le fameux article article 4
donc voilà donc c'est une bonne chose
car aujourd'hui un projet de loi a été
soumis au Conseil d'État alors depuis
hier on en sait un peu plus sur ce
calendrier d'abord sur l'intitulé exact
du projet de loi alors je l'ai noté hein
parce que je l'ai pas encore bien en
tête projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération et la simplification de
la rénovation de l'habitat dégradé et
des grandes opérations d'aménagementon
dans tact voilà l'intitulé exact du
projet de loi qui a été présenté hier en
conseil des ministres et qui sera
examiné puisqu'on a une date à partir du
22 janvier à l'Assemblée nationale donc
c'est l'assemblée qui sera saisie en
premier sur ce projet de loi et donc on
peut penser que assez rapidement à
l'issue de l'examen du projet de loi par
l'Assemblée nous soyons saisis ici au
Sénat et donc bien sûr sur un texte qui
relèvera de notre commission au fond
donc nous allons pouvoir en tout cas
l'enrichir c'est ce que nous essayons
toujours de faire ici au Sénat d'une
façon qui soit sérieuse mais on souhaite
toujours voilà tant que faire se peut
enrichir amender les textes pour que ça
aille dans la finalité qui est ici porté
par l'intitulé même du texte
effectivement l'accélération et la
simplification de la rénovation de
l'habitat dégradé ce pourquoi nous
sommes tous convaincus qu'il faut aller
dans ce sens-là mais nous voulons aussi
enrichir à partir de l'expérience de nos
territoires et c'est la raison pour
laquelle vos témoignages ce matin nous
seront particulièrement précieux parce
que vous êtes l'un comme l'autre des
mairres des mairres engagés depuis
longtemps sur ces sujets-là qui
connaissaient dans vos territoires qui
dans vos communes qui ne sont pas les
mêmes qui n'ont pas euh voilà les mêmes
euh les mêmes problématiques en tout cas
les mêmes configurations et donc c'est
extrêmement important que vous puissiez
aujourd'hui nous apporter vos
témoignages et puis bien sûr comment
vous avez trava travailler et ce que
vous avez proposé à travers votre
rapport et si aujourd'hui au vu du
projet de loi voilà vous êtes déjà
satisfait par rapport à des propositions
qui ont été intégrées dans ce projet de
loi et d'autres qui ne le seraient pas
encore ou pourrai l'être dans le cadre
de la discussion
parlementaire donc c'est important et à
partir de votre expérience de la
contribution de nombreux maires dont
ceux du réseau des villes contre
l'habitat indigne que vous avez créé je
crois que la force et l'intérêt de votre
travail sont le pragmatisme le souci de
l'efficacité quand j'ai pu moi-même
m'entretenir avec vous par téléphone
j'ai bien compris combien votre ligne de
conduite ave votre boussole était bien
celle de votre expérience vécue sur le
terrain de vos difficultés rencontrées
des obstacles que vous connaissez encore
mais surtout de cette volonté d'être le
plus pragmatique possible pour obtenir
des résultats avec un souci d'efficacité
directement puisée dans le concret de
votre action municipale donc voilà donc
donc nous organiserons donc très
rapidement je le dis à l'ensemble de nos
commissaires une consultation des élus
qui nous permettra là aussi de continuer
à enrichir nos travaux vous savez que le
président de l'archer a mis en place une
plateforme de consultation des élus que
nous utilisons de plus en plus souvent
pour pouvoir s'appuyer sur des
témoignages concrets pratiques à
l'échelle de tout le territoire national
nous avons pensé que sur ce sujet-là sur
ce véhicule législatif là et bien
effectivement on pouvait utiliser cette
plateforme dédiée du Sénat pour
recueillir justement les avis les
témoignages et les propositions des élus
qui sont directement concernés par ces
sujet par ces sujets-là en vue de
l'examen du projet de loi donc je vous
invite enfin à noter mes chers collègues
que nous pourrons poursuivre l'échange
de ce matin sur le terrain puisque
monsieur Mathieu anotin le maire de
Saint-Denis a invité la Commission dans
sa ville le jeudi 25 janvier 2024 donc
donc je vous invite bien évidemment pour
ceux qui sont intéressés à faire ce
déplacement à Saint-Denis de vous
inscrire auprès du secrétariat de la
commission voilà c'est un déplacement
qu'on peut faire rapidement puisque
Saint-Denis est quand même et qui ne
nécessite pas trop de de difficultés en
terme de de déplacement mais je crois
que ça sera très intéressant de d'aller
directement sur le terrain lorsque
j'avais donc été chargé du rapport au
niveau de la commission des affaires
économiques avec la présidente Sophie
prima de l'époque on avait d'ailleurs
fait des déplacements déjà en saints
puisqu'on était allé je regarde Fabien
Guay à la fois à aubervillier mais
également à Montfermeil et puis nous
avions fait bien sûr un déplacement à
Marseille mais également on avait voulu
faire un déplacement en Guadeloupe et en
Martinique parce que la question là
encore de l'habitat dégradé elle se pose
de façon certes différente mais elle est
extrêmement et au compbi prignante donc
je vous invite à retenir cette date
jeudi 25 janvier pour aller à
l'invitation oh ça va être le matin avec
certainement jusqu'en début d'après-midi
Serge voilà hein donc le programme est
pas encore établi mais ça sera ça donc
on va on va vous communiquer très
rapidement pour que vous puissiez vous
inscrire donc voilà vous avez compris
que nous sommes pleinement mobilisés et
que l'enjeu de de ce texte est pour nous
extrêmement important mais ce qui va
nous guider c'est vraiment de faire un
outil qui soit un outil efficace dans un
domaine où nous avons tous à cœur de
trouver des solutions voilà donc je vous
propose de vous laisser la parole vous
allez commencer madame le Maire ensuite
Monsieur le Maire prendra donc la parole
et après bien sûr nous ouvrirons les
questions à l'ensemble de nos
commissaires madame le Maire je vous
laisse la parole très volontiers merci
madame la Présidente bonjour mesdames et
messieurs évidemment je merci d'abord
pour pour cette invitation et en tout
cas on est ravi de pouvoir être parmi
vous ce matin pour nous présenter le
fruit de voilà d'un d'un travail que que
nous avons entrepris avec euh avec
Mathieu et je suis d'autant plus
heureuse que c'est un un travail
transpartisan donc voilà ça aussi il
faut le signaler ça a été quelque chose
qui a été réalisé aussi en un temps
record donc je vous ferai si vous si
vous me le permettez une petite
introduction Mathieu continuera je
reprendrai la parole puisque nous sommes
un peu articulés pour que ça soit le
plus fluide possible et que pour que
nous ayons le plus de temps aussi
consacré aux échanges parce que je pense
que c'est ce qui est intéressant pour
nous aussi de vous entendre et bien sûr
d'essayer de répondre à vos questions
voilà donc vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente lutter contre l'habitat
indigne c'est parl d'un sujet d'ampleur
je crois qu'on ne peut plus nier
l'ampleur de ce sujet-là et euh on s'est
rendu compte et je tiens à préciser
aussi que nous avons consulté énormément
de maires aussi Mathieu de son côté avec
ses équipes moi-même avec mon premier
adjoint d'autres d'autres maires euh
puisqu'il a fallu réaliser ce rapport en
un temps euh assez assez court donc on
s'est réparti le travail mais toujours
est-il qu'on s'est rendu compte que
c'est c'est quelque chose qui existe sur
l'ensemble du territoire français qu'on
soit dans les grandes métropoles qu'on
soit en territoire rural je crois qu'il
y a a il y a plus de euh il y a plus de
territoires qui ne soi pas impactés par
cette thématique là alors c'est vrai euh
on sait très bien aussi que le le fait
de ne pas traiter cette thématique là
peut avoir une issue dramatique on l'a
vu je ne vais pas revenir le sujet sur
le sujet vous le connaissez sans doute
mieux que nous encore alors c'est vrai
que euh quand j'ai eu le le ministre
clin au téléphone il m'avait dit deux
choses il m'a dit il nous faut un
véhicule législatif différent alors je
tiens à préciser qu'on a on n'est pas en
train de dire qu'il n'existait rien mais
il y a peut-être moyen peut-être de de
de de renforcer peut-être ce véhicule
législatif mais tout cela vous
appartient bien sûr à vous mais surtout
avoir une boîte à outils et c'est vrai
que on se rend compte que finalement au
fur à mesure où nous avancions de ce
rapport c'est devenu un défi collectif
que nous partageions avec tout le monde
et surtout un souci on a nous les maires
et madame la Présidente l'a dit très
justement nous avons un souci parce que
nous sommes des gens pragmatiques nous
sommes des gens au quotidien qui qui
vivons ce qui se passe dans nos cités et
ce il y a un vrai une vraie nécessité de
de simplification et surtout une
simplification dans un souci
d'efficacité voilà je tenais à à le dire
de cette
manière-là et en tout cas la la mission
qui n'a qui nous a été confiée et je je
suis ravie que que le ministre vergrit a
repris repris cette mission après
monsieur cllein c'était l'idée première
c'était de fluidifier la chaîne
administrative et financière et donc ce
qui fait l'objet à ce jour donc des 24
propositions qui ont qui ont été
travaillées qui ont été réalisées et je
laisserai tout de suite la parole à
Mathieu anoutin pour nous présenter
peut-être le premier axe
Mathieu si ça convient madame la
Présidente bien évidemment bien sûr et
j'ai omis de d'accueillir aussi et de
remercier de leur présence je crois vos
premières adjoints respectifs à l'un
comme à l'autre et aussi des services
donc bien évidemment on est très heureux
aussi que vous soyez au côté de vos
mères
merci merci Madame président madame la
Présidente cher commissaire des affaires
économiques bon moi je suis très content
d'être ici vraiment parmi vous pour
pouvoir avoir cet échange franc j'allais
dire on est pile au bon moment c'est on
est au moment où on a un calendrier avec
une perspective législative et où en
même temps on est pas encore dedans
vraiment et donc on n'est pas sur un
texte de loi là on est sur la
présentation d'une démarche d'un rapport
qui va par définition bien au-delà d'un
texte législative il compris parce qu'il
embrasse notamment tout le champ
réglementaire parce que ce n'est pas que
dans une loi euh qu'on dans une loi
qu'on réglera le le problème protéiforme
de l'habitat indigne moi je voulais
juste avant de démarrer insister sur le
fait que cette
problématique bien sûr elle est très
présente dans les grands centres
métropolitain et en particulier dans les
zones périphériques des grands centres
métropolitains mais pas que c'est une
problématique nationale aujourd'hui qui
touche certes dans des des proportions
moins importantes mais également la
ruralité de manière extrêmement
importante avec des ressorts différents
pas celui des grandes copros mais où
néanmoins on est dans le champ de
l'habitat indigne dehabitat individuel
du petit collectif qu'on retrouve
maintenant régulièrement et vous l'avez
évoqué madame la Présidente je voulais
insister là-dessus et la question de
l'autre mère où on est aussi on n pas pu
aller en outreem c'était un nos regrets
mais parce que les les choses était trop
compliqué en terme de délai mais où là
s'il y a 400000 logements en France
métropolitaine qui sont du ressort de
l'habitat indigne parle pas de
l'habitat du mallogement version entre
guillemets de la Fondation abépierre là
on parle vraiment de des chiffr du PNLHI
sur l'habit ind dans les outr M c'est
100000 donc on est 25 % du stock enfin
20 % du stock national et aujourd'hui
dans les autres mèes donc donc quand on
a une problématique très concrètement
concerne entre 1 million et 1 million et
demi de personnes de manière direct on
est sur un problème de masse moi je
remercie vraiment la présidente que
Dominique estr on a échangé longement au
téléphone et je veux dire que je partage
pleinement son avis qui a été de dire
que ce genre de sujet ne se traite pas à
la va vite au milieu de l'été et je
tiens à dire qu'en tout cas ce n'était
pas notre demande ni à Michel Lutz ni à
moi-même on le voit bien on a besoin de
complexité et on n pas besoin de
d'outils jeis dire vite fait magique
mais qu'il faut aller en profondeur pour
être bien sûr de ne pas faire de bêtises
parce que c'est le genre de sujet sur
lequel on revient pas tous les 6 mois et
et et que finalement il ne faut pas
rater ces opportunités le sentiment que
j'ai
et comme ancien parlementairire dans une
précédente législature c'est que on on
on a là la voix d'un d'un d'un vrai
enfin d'une vraie compréhension
transpartisane que cette problématique
aujourd'hui elle touche partout ce qu'on
n pas forcément eu ce qu'on avit pas les
uns et les autres pu susciter dans
peut-être de manière aussi loin dans
d'autres lois et quand je parle de
transpartisan je parle
au-delà évidemment des acteurs
politiques dans la société dans les
grands
réseaux de propriétaires de locata terre
aujourd'hui il y a eu une prise de
conscience qu'il faut que globalement
nous nous attaquions à cette
problématique parce que ce n'est pas une
situation normale que dans notre pays 6e
puissance mondiale on tolère que un
million et demi de personnes habitent
dans un habitat qui menacee directement
leur
santé alors pour cela comme le disait
Michel on a essayé de regrouper nos
propositions dans quatre blocs qu'on va
vous présenter je veux juste le dire dès
le départ c'est que à la fois c'était la
commande et c'était notre souhait que
notre rapport ne soit pas un un rapport
finalement qui traite toutes les
problématique de l'habitat indigne et en
particulier c'est ni un rapport moral
entre guillemets comme on peut le
retrouver dans les associations ni un
rapport de droit pénal nous nous sommes
des maires nous sommes là pour agir et
donc on a parlé de ce qu'on connaissait
à savoir les freins qu'il y a dans notre
action au quotidien il y a eu des
propositions vousz récemment du maire de
Marseille sur la question
de d'augmenter la judiciarisation
potentielle des marchands de sommeil de
définir ses
délits je dis pas que c'est pas bien du
tout on peut même dire que c'est
éventuellement complémentaire mais là
l'enjeu c'est l'amélioration des outils
à disposition des acteurs de terrain les
communes et bien souvent leurs EPCI pour
pour résumer pour pouvoir agir donc le
le le premier bloc euh de proposition
euh qui est finalement celui qu'on que à
ce stade en tout cas on retrouve aussi
le plus dans le projet de loi c'est
normal c'était l'essence euh pour les
communes c'est de travailler sur une
redéfinition une amélioration de
l'existant et une redéfinition du régime
des régimes d'expropriation préemption
euh concernant l'habitat indigne avec
notre première proposition la création
d'un régime ad hoc
spécifique sur la question dehabit
indigne pourquoi ça aujourd'hui on a un
régime spécifique sur l'habitat indigne
qui existe qui est le régime pour tous
ceux qui qui connaissent vous êtes très
nombreux classiquement dit de la loi
Vivien la loi Vivien qui intervient
quand finalement arrive soit
l'insalubrité
irrémédiable soit
la le péril définitif de de de
l'immeuble imminent définitif avec en
plus la jurisprudence qui a rajouté des
conditions qui a durci aujourd'hui
l'accès au Viviens en devant faire des
démonstrations économique y compris en
intégrant les coups de démolition enfin
qui ont tendance à restreindre son
utilisation finalement sur les immeubles
qui menacent de de s'écrouler dont la la
preuve en est faite tout de suite et que
vraiment on ne peut plus rien faire sauf
que cette situation si elle est bien
compréhensible on va dire dans
dans dans sa philosophie qui est dire
finalement c'est pas à la puissance
publique de régler des problèmes de
droit privé notamment par le B
d'expropriation c'est au copropriétaire
de se de se débrouiller sauf que le et
finalement si la finance publique elle
l'exproprie elle doit l'exproprier sur
une motivation d'une utilité publique
qui se manifeste par la destination de
ce que l'on veut faire du logement
social une école une route un machin un
truc un truc d'intérêt public la
difficulté c'est que aujourd'hui quand
on constate une défaillance ça veut dire
que sauf à manifester à j'ai à tricher
si vous me permettez l'expression en
finalement en en disant bah ici on va
faire du logement social alors que c'est
peut-être pas forcément intérêt je
prends l'exemple de ma commune
dans le centreville de Saint-Denis c'est
le cas aussi à l'échelle de la ville il
y a 52% 50 % de logements sociaux au
titre de la loi SR dans le logement dans
le centreville il faut y rajouter qu'il
y a 30 % de l'habitat privé qui est de
l'habitat indigne vous voyez bien que on
va pas faire
basculer 30 % d'habitat dans alors qu'il
y a déjà 50 % de logement social et donc
oui là ça ça finirait de déséquilibrer
complètement les choses alors qu'au
contraire notre mouvement est plutôt
dans un mouvement d'essayer de trouver
une forme d'harmonie
d'équilibrer d'équilibrer les
choses on parle de la théorie sans
parler du fait que y a un moment donné
tout ça coûte énormément d'argent parce
que quand on parle de logement logements
sociaux c'est bien normal il faut qu'on
vente aux opérateurs avec des décottes
gigantesques qui sont pour l'habitat
dans nos villes de 1 à 10 c'estd que on
va acheter 10 un bien dans l'habitat
indigne parce que aujourd'hui il est
estimé par rapport à la valeur V
potentiel donc comparer à ce qu'il y est
autour et on va le vendre un à un
opérateur d'urgence sociale pour qu'il
le rénve parce que ça vaut pas plus cher
en vrai ça c'est la problématique très
concrète àquel on est et donc cette
problématique elle abouti à ça à cette
frise ceux qui viendront à saint-i ne
verront plus cet immeuble enfin là ils
verront un trou à la place que nous
avons enfin réussi à le démolir mais
d'un immeuble qui est en face de la
mairie de Saint-Denis dont le premier
arrêté de péril est pris en 2000 voilà
don l'arrêté de péril imminent qui
provoque l'évacuation remonte à 2016
2017 2016-
2017 et l'évacuation démar sensuit les
expropriations on le démolit en 2023 et
on va mettre 3 4 ans normal à le
reconstruire et donc il sera livré 2026
2027 et donc un schéma qui pour traiter
un problème alors que il y a eu au total
16 arrêtés unalubrité péril N qui n'ont
jamais été levés mais qui se sont
cumulés les uns aux autres euh 26 ans 27
ans pour traiter un immeuble une
copropriété de 20 logements euh avec
plein de difficultés alors je je je com
dire euh euh on est dans le cas extrême
probablement qu'il y a eu aussi un peu à
un moment donné
d'inefficacité de l'action publique
locale probablement qu'il y a eu des des
jeux il y a eu aussi d'autres phénomènes
et là je vous ai pris le cas extrême on
arrive quand même à faire un peu plus
vite aujourd'hui mais mais si on dit
plus vite ça va être 15 ans dans le
meilleur des cas pourquoi parce que
aujourd'hui on perd énormément de temps
de là jusqu'à là en fait aujourd'hui la
loi pour la puissance publique elle nous
contraint à attendre attendre que
l'immeuble continue de se dégrader pour
pouvoir déclencher les outils de
puissance publique alors même qu'on a
des périls divers et variés voilà et
donc nous la philosophie de notre
première proposition qui se retrouve
quasi complètement enfin je veux dire
c'est c'est très largement inspiré c'est
l'article 3 du du projet de loi visis à
dire il faut qu'on crée un régime
spécifique qui permet aux collectivités
d'agir beaucoup plut tôt dans la chaîne
c'est-à-dire dès qu'on a des périls même
non imminents des insalbrités même non
irrémédiaable mais que il y a une
inaction des copropriétaires euh sur la
base de prescriptions qui sont données
par l'autorité locale par l'autorité
locale et que cela finalement deviennent
comme dans le Vivien aujourd'hui un
motif d'intérêt légitime d'intérêt
public qui déclenche la qui déclenche
l'action publique et qui du coup
actirement enlève aussi le corollaire de
la destination et donc n'oblige pas non
plus les collectivités à devoir faire du
logement social et cetera à aggraver
leurs finances et cetera et cetera et
cetera voilà j'ai pris un peu de temps
mais parce que c'est vraiment
disons-le la proposition phare de de ce
qu'on ait de de notre rapport et qui se
retrouve aujourd'hui on en est très
content avec Michel dans le dans le dans
le projet de loi alors je vais vous
détailler le reste parce que très
rapidement j'ai pris je je vais prendre
moins de temps évidemment il y a notre
deuxième proposition que vous trouvez
dans le rapport vise pour le coup à
sécuriser l'ensemble des procédures
existence qui resteront utiles le
vivient avec son accès qui a été trop
restreint la procéure de la carence en
en particulier dans les grandes
copropriétés qui est très difficile à
mettre en œuvre avec aussi on l'IT pas
écrit comme ça dans le rapport mais
franchement c'est c'est c'est très
pertinent dans la proposition de loi sur
la question de la capacité finalement à
séparer les copropriétés pour pouvoir
agir les sisss de copropriété quand on a
une copropriété comme à Marseille par
exemple on estvoqué tout à l'heure où il
y a 3000 copropriétaires bon ben pour
pouvoir espérer agir il faut commencer
par euh ceinder et aujourd'hui c'est
toujours pareil c'est serpent qui se m
la queue il faut que tout le monde soit
d'accord pour cinder et donc du coup
bref ça marche pas quoi chacun comprend
bien et là on parle effectivement de
dizaines d'années euh pour exproprier
comme maich sous bois dans les dans les
dans les copropriétés du chîn pointu euh
qui pourtant a bénéficié de tous les
outils existants hors code Yenne et
cetera et et les choses avancent mais
avancent à une vitesse qui n'est pas
compatible
j'insiste et après j'accélérerai
vraiment parce que je sens que j'ai été
beaucoup trop long sur le point 3 qui
est finalement un peu le corolaire qui
vise à instaurer là on n pas du le
domaine législatif néanmoins je pense
que c'est extrêmement pertinent si on
arrive à faire en sorte que ce sujet
rentre aussi dans le débat public de
commencer à instaurer une méthode
nationale de décotte des logements de
l'habit indigne je l'évoqué tout à
l'heure un de nos autres gros sujets
c'est que aujourd'hui une collectivité
va exproprier euh et bien le juge de
l'expropriation parce qu'on est quand
même disonsle jamais d'accord à plus
forte raison si le propriétaire est
malveillant et du ressort du marchand de
sommeil il ira immédiatement devant le
jugexpropriation et nous on a des cas de
figure complètement ahurissants où on a
des valeurs vénales potentielles décidé
par le juge de l'expropriation qui sont
supérieurs à trois fois à quatre
fois la vie des domaines qui sur lequel
on a parfois réussi à obtenir un certain
nombre de décotes parce que le juge son
principe c'est d'abord c'est son droit
mais que aujourd'hui il a pas d'outil
pour estimer si ce n'est les outils de
constater ce qu'il y a concrètement
autour
autour donc ça c'est il y a aussi
derrière disons-le il y a une question
d'opérationnalité pour les les communes
il a une question morale de dire que on
arrête dans notre pays d'enrichir des
marchands de sommeil avec de l' argent
public parce que aujourd'hui c'est quand
même ce que les collectivités sont
parfois contraintes de faire avec un
arbitrage terrible de dire l'inaction
ou la récompense de personnages
malveillant sachant que la
judiciarisation sur l'aspect pénal on
voit bien elle est nécessaire mais on
voit aussi très largement ces limites
des enquêtes qui sont longues avec peu
de moyens pour la justice avec des
difficultés à matérialiser les preuves
parce qu'on ça on a on a souvent là on
aura d'ailleurs très bientôt un demain
le résultat d'unun grand procès de
l'habitat indigne à bobini vendredi
pardon avec 27 victimes combien de
personnes j'y suis allé représenter la
ville moi-même à la-bas sur les 27
familles victimes dans les 27
appartement trois qui sont venus qui
sont venus témoigner et c'était déjà
très content parce que il avaient au
moins des des
représentants autres
malheureusement n'ont pas fait ce choix
alors j'accélère très j'accélère
j'accélère j'accélère on a un point 4
sur le sur développer les financements
du déficit à Lilo je m'attarde pas
dessus mais c'est quand même très
important de voir que bien
souvent c'est un sujet qu'on a avec Lana
c'est les conséquences finalement de l'
d'un immeuble d'habite indine sur le
reste de l'ilo avec parfois des
copropriétaires qui n'ont rien demandé
on aura une autre proposition qui est
là-dessus notamment dans les cas les
plus graves d'effondrement mais qu'on
puisse intervenir et et avoir ouvrir des
financements pardon sur les
copropriétaires qui sont autour
finalement de la Vita indigne euh les
biens confisqués euh par la grasque dans
le casadre de laabit indig on
souhaiterait qu'il puisse être rétrocédé
aux collectivités au profit des projets
urbains disons-le plutôt à l'euro
symbolique parce que sinon on on est le
serpent qui se mort la queue si
finalement l'état nous le revend au prix
de la valeur vénale potentielle bon et
ben ça ça ne fait que renforcer les
difficultés euh voilà et euh un un un
point 7 pardon euh extrêmement important
pour euh pour les communes euh visant à
la nécessaire renforcement de
l'ingénierie au service de la lutte
contre l'habitat indigne euh là on est
quand même dans une fragmentation euh de
de des différentes ingénieries euh avec
des par disonsl des injustices entre les
communes euh qui exerc aussi la
compétence de l'État via via des SCHS
mais qui sont pas financés pour Leit
parce que la dernière loi de financement
elle date de 1983 donc elle correspond
plus vraiment à la à la réalité et où
nous on le voit bien ce qui marche c'est
quand même quand on unifie les
procédures euh si un jour on y va sur
l'insalubrité mais qu'en fait finalement
on a pas la compétence péril et que en
même temps on n' pas le contact avec les
inspecteurs d'urbanisme voir avec la
police municipal quand il y a un
commerce qui lui-même a potentiellement
dégradé les choses là-dessus on s'épuise
chacun dans son stylo là où il faudrait
avoir une logique si vous me permettez
l'analogie un petit peu pour la question
des commerces un peu comme des codafs où
on arrive et on est en capacité d'avoir
un diagnostic 360 sur un logement un
immeuble et en tout cas c'est je pense
que au minimum dans les grandes
métropoles qui ont les moyens de
développer ses ingénieries il faut viser
d'aller dans ce sens et avoir une
réflexion sur comment est-ce qu'on on
crée peut-être à d'autres échelles des
ingénieers pour les petites communes ça
n n pas complètement la réponse mais
c'est un vrai sujet qu'on a
posé du coup au gouvernement parce que
pour le coup des ingénieries de qualité
elles ne peuvent pas se développer à
l'échelle d'une commune de quelques
milliers d'habitants c'est tout
simplement impossible pour autant on l'a
dit le problème il est réel et il
existe voilà essentiellement on a aussi
une mesure sur le portage foncier mais
qui est non
déterminante mich madame le Maire vous
reprenez la parole oui oui merci madame
la Présidente alors je vais essayer
d'être synthétique puisque tout le monde
a le rapport sous les yeux donc l'axe 2
on parle beaucoup de de la comment
est-ce qu'on peut faciliter
l'intervention des acteurs du logement
parce que ça aussi c'était une question
qu'on s'est rapidement posée alors
peut-être et je mets tout ça au
conditionnel hein bien évidemment en
donnant à tous les acteurs et aux
propriétaires les moyens de mieux faire
parce qu'on se rend compte que la
volonté de mieux faire est souvent là
elle est présente mais il y a pas
toujours les moyens qui qui vont et
peut-être agir de façon plus autonome
fluidifier peut-être cette chaîne des
acteurs et Mathieu l'a très justement
illustré tout à l'heure par rapport à
l'immeuble dont il a parlé la puissance
publique d'intervention c'est souvent
des interventions qui sont lourdes qui
sont coûteuses qui sont très très
longues et qui qui qui qui génèent quand
même beaucoup de beaucoup de temps
beaucoup d'énergie pour finalement
arriver à un résultat qui est très très
délayé dans le temps et ça c'est quelque
chose qui nous pré occupe beaucoup
également alors partager aussi la la
charge de la mise en sécurité des
occupants et la sauvegarde des immeubles
je crois que ça va de soi on va pas
reciter encore les exemples dramatiques
que nous avons connus mais
malheureusement nous les élus locaux
nous souvons on est on est on est juste
pas outier il faut dire les choses comme
elles sont nous ne sommes pas
suffisamment outillers nous n'arrivons
pas à réagir au signalement assez
précocément assez rapidement nous
n'arrivons pas euh nous attendons
malheureusement les sinistres qui sont
avérés pour pouvoir avoir une une
fonction d'action derrière et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut vraiment euh
qu'il faut vraiment euh euh faire
évoluer il faut il faut vraiment qu'on
puisse agir à ce niveau-là alors je vais
peut-être juste vous citer quelques
propositions phare elles sont toutes
bien sûr notées dans l'axe 2 de ce
rapport alors un acteur majeur et un
acteurs phare ou les acteurs ce sont les
syndicques on s'est beaucoup intéressé à
la question du syndque
et on se rend compte que les
interventions du syndique ne sont pas de
qualité
égalei j'entends que ça réagit dans la
salle et croyez-moi ça nous ça me fait
très plaisir de vous entendre réagir et
c'est vrai pour les cas les plus graves
on imaginait qu'on pourrait peut-être
imaginer un syndicque de copropriété à
caractère public ou d'intérêt général je
ne sais pas comment il faudrait le
nommer mais tout cela vous appartient à
vous aussi mesdames et
messieurs responsabil bien sûr les
copropriétaires et on avait envisagé
très vite par exemple dans la
programmation des travaux dans les
copropriétés de réaliser un diagnostic
technique global et complet à aucun
moment on ne fait ce de diagnosti
complet et ce qui est encore de notre
point de vue le plus intéressant un
diagnostic du point de vue structurel et
on voit bien on voit bien avec ce qui
s'est passé avec malheureusement les
exemples que nous avons que la question
de la structure n'est jamais prise en
compte assez tôt et dans des contrôles
réguliers ou très en amont de du
dispositif alors évidemment une fois
qu'on a dit tout ça il faut aussi
pouvoir avoir les moyens et donc on
s'est rendu compte en échangeant bien
sûr beaucoup avec les acteurs du
logement mais aussi avec nos collègues
maires il faudrait peut-être améliorer
les les dispositif de préfinancement
pour les travaux euh les aides publiques
des aides publiques bien sûr et le
financement du reste à charge on se rend
compte que dans ces copropriétés
dégradées souvent on est face à un
public fragile on est face à un public
qui malheureusement ne n'arrive pas à
financer les travaux nécessaires pour
éviter le pire donc l'idée c'est de dire
comment est-ce qu'on peut faire comment
est-ce qu'on peut trouver au niveau de
l'État une aide à ce niveau-là et
surtout pour le reste à charge on sait
très bien que tous ces occupants sont
des gens modestes ce sont des gens qui
ne peuvent pas euh rentrer dans le cadre
normal du système bancaire traditionnel
et donc il faudrait aussi impérativement
réfléchir à la façon dont on peut ou
l'État peut préfinancer tous ces travaux
nécessaires alors un dispositif que que
tout le monde connaît et nous avons la
certitude et monsieur le ministre nous
l'avait assuré quand nous l'avons vu
l'élargissement du dispositif de
Normandie évidemment qui nous semble
garanti pour l'instant jusqu'en 2030
mais voilà aussi un un vecteur qui qui
nous semblait intéressant et ce que j'ai
oublié de dire tout à l'heure en en
introduction c'est que la mission au
départ
consigner tout ce qui tourne autour du
logement indigne monsieur le ministre a
souhaité l'élargir aux copropriétés
dégradé et aux immeubles de grande
hauteur parce que nous sommes quand même
un certain nombre de mes en France à
devoir traiter des immeubles de de
grande hauteur et on voit bien nous
avons l'exemple à mulouse un immeuble de
grande hauteur qui est classé IGH pour
deux étages donc on est en train de de
de se dire qu'il faudrait peut-être
aussi trouver une solution alors je
lance les choses un brûle pour point
est-ce que la solution du numérique
peut-être une solution par partielle on
ne sait pas puisque maintenant on est en
capacité aussi de sécuriser un immeuble
avec le
numérique on sait très bien que ce sont
les PC de sécurité avec la PR humaine
H24 qui grève aussi les budgets des
charges ça nous le savons aussi nous
n'avons pas la solution alors on se dit
est-ce que on a la possibilité je
reprends volontiers l'exemple qui nous
concerne à mououse est-ce qu'en
neutralisant les deux derniers étages
mais on sait aussi que ça pose des des
problèmes avec l'organisation des
fluides et tout ce qu'il faut pour faire
vivre un immeuble voilà je pose on pose
les choses là on n pas de on a vraim on
a vraiment pas de solution par contre on
y un certain nombre à ne pas savoir
comment gérer tous ces immeubles de
grande hauteur puisqu'on sait que la
réglementation s'est crispée aux
alentours des années 2015 et que du coup
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de copropriétés
qui se retrouvent à nouveau dégradé dans
ces immeubles de de grande hauteur voilà
un petit peu j'ai j'ai extrait quelques
quelques exemples de la problématique
qui tourne autour des acteurs également
du
logement merci madame la
Présidente très très rapidement le Tr
bloc vise on peut pas parler d'habit
indigne sans réfléchir à la question de
ceux qui l'occupe et de comment est-ce
qu'on les protège mieux parce que
aujourd'hui on a vraiment des cas de de
de de maltraitance qui sont qui sont à
l'œuvre moi je veux signaler que pour la
question de la protection y compris la
question du relogement dans l'habitat
indigne on est quand même régulièrement
confronté j'ai pas de proportion en tête
mais enfin on va dire allez dans un/ers
dans la moitié des cas enfin
régulièrement en tout cas a une
problématique c'est que la situation
administrative de l'occupant bloque la
situation pourquoi parce que c situation
administrative elle empêche le recours
au dispositif d'hébergement d'urgence
classique qu'on peut connaître moi je
c'est un constat que nous on fait alors
je sais qu'il y a beaucoup de débats en
ce moment sur le sujet c'est d'actu
mais que néanmoins s'il y a une mesure
que moi je trouve que le Sénat a adopté
dans le cadre du projet de loi
immigration que sur laquelle je veux
attirer votre attention c'est celle qui
avait été proposée par le sénateur Yann
brossa visant à donner comme on peut
l'avoir pour les victimes du terrorisme
sur les victimes de l'habitat indigne un
titre de séjour provisoire pour faire en
sorte que les collectivités ne soient
pas contraintes en fait à mettre des
personnes à grand frais à l'hôtel
pendant des années et des années parce
que aujourd'hui c'est la seule solution
que nous donne la loi aujourd'hui si on
veut
traiter quelqu'un enfin une situation
qui est dans la d'habiter indigne on est
obligé de reloger les gens on n pas le
droit et c'est normal c'est la loi et si
la personne qui a un bail même si n'a
pas de papier on a l'obligation de la
reloger et donc aujourd'hui nous
dépensons des dizaines des centaines de
milliers d'euros pour mettre des gens
dans des hôtels pour des histoires de
situation administrative c'est
honnêtement une situation qui est
ubuesque pour toutes les collectivités
locales donc moi je voulais quand même
saluer cette avancée du débat on verra
comment les choses suivront mais qui a
été porté par votre noble assemblée et
en tout cas qui nous permettrait pour
nous de régler quasiment ce cette
problématique que l'on a pointé on
l'avait nous plutôt proposé dans le sens
inverse de dire d'ouvrir de manière
dérogatoire euh les résidences sociales
les résidences d'urgence au-delà de la
situation administrative euh pas l'accès
au HLM classique mais sur les dimensions
de
l'urgence voilà donc il a il y a
plusieurs manière de traiter le sujet
mais en tout cas on ne peut pas ne pas
traiter le sujet si on veut être
efficace demain on on on on souhaite
pouvoir améliorer le droit des occupants
qu'il
soit locatair ou
propriétaire en particulier sur la
question de l'information il y a
énormément il y a aussi beaucoup de
mesures sur la question question de
l'information des propriétaires avec
quand on est face à des syndicques qui
font pas forcément le travail et cetera
pas forcément le relais donc une
meilleure information des propriétaires
elle est absolument cruciale et dans le
projet de loi il y aura des disposition
dessus Michel l'évoqué il y a aussi sur
la question de la protection des
occupants il y a finalement leur
faciliter la vie au au au quand il est
toujour par la logique de prévention
quand il est pas trop tard en facilitant
en donnant un accès au crédit c'est
aussi une proposition de la banque des
territoires qui a rendu un rapport à
côté qui vise à donner pour les
coproprités en difficulté et pas que en
tout cas pour pour pas qu'elle ne
bascule un crédit très prosaïquement
aujourd'hui vous êtes probablement il y
a des copropriétaires comme moi dans mon
immeuble on doit faire un ravalement et
ben on va mettre 4 ans à réunir l'argent
avant de pouvoir voilà et sauf que 4 ans
après et ben ça c'est euh 4 30
dégradation supplémentaires et on n' pas
pu finalement casser la chaîne de la
dégradation
euh j'accélère il y a une proposition
qu'on avit pas du tout dans le Scope et
c'est c'est c'est quand on est la
Bordeaux qu'elle a pu vraiment émerger
remonter toujours pareil sur la question
de la protection mais là des victimes
indirectes je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
euh quand on a eu tous les effondrements
à Marseille euh à Bordeaux l à Lille euh
il y a des victimes indirectes c'est qui
c'est des personnes qui ont bien
entretenu leur immeuble qui n'ont jamais
eu un problème qui n'ont jamais eu aucun
sujet mais qui avaient le malheur
d'habité à côté d'un immeuble qui lui
s'est effondré et il y a des gens qui
aujourd'hui on parle pas de là pour le
coup on ne parle pas de centaines de
milliers de personnes mais dans notre
pays on parle de dizaines de personnes
de centaines de personnes qui au moment
où je vous parle sont dans des
situations humaines absolument
dramatiques alors qu'elles non rien fait
et aujourd'hui la seule réponse étatique
en terme de solidarité nationale c'est
la réponse à urentiel dont on sait
qu'elle se déclenchera que dans 10 ans
et donc aujourd'hui on a des gens qui
sont qui ont un crédit sur le dos qui
n'ont plus le droit
d'accéder à leur appartement parce que
leur immeuble a été fragilisé par un
l'effondrement d'un autre immeuble et
moi je pense que là il faut qu'on ait
une dynamique de création d'un fond de
garantie pour ces victimes là c'est pas
des millions d'euros parce que c'est on
parle de dizaines de de de de personnes
très concrètement au moins dans la phase
d'attente de la la séquence que la
séquence le temps que la séquence
assurancielle rentre en jeu encore une
fois un peu sur le modèle de ce qui
avait été imaginé pour les victimes de
de de terrorisme
euh
voilà et évidemment il y a aussi enfin
voilà il y a il y a un su de comment
est-ce qu'on Michel l'évoqué je reviens
pas dessus mais comment on articule tout
ça avec les diagnostiques techniques
globaux qui euh dont on souhaite qui
concerne bien sûr les logements comme
c'est beaucoup le cas aujourd'hui mais
qui puisse s'élargir à la question de la
structure de l'immeuble aujourd'hui on a
euh trop peu de choses qui visent la
structure de l'immeuble et qui vise à
prévenir les effondrements notamment
comme ceux qu'on a pu
connaître il m'appartient de continuer
merci Madame donc dans ce rapport on
s'est intéressé aussi aux mesures
coercitives envers les propriétaires
indélicats ça a déjà été nommé euh je
sais madame dans votre rapport vous y
avez beaucoup travaillé également mais
malheureusement ça reste une actualité
c'est une actualité prégante dans nos
dans nos villes hein je crois que voilà
il faut pas le nier
alors on a on a besoin de de d'avoir des
moyens allouer sur ce contentieux là
parce que on se sent souvent très démuni
que ça soit dans les
juridictions par rapport aux forces de
l'ordre également parce qu'on a on a pas
de vrais moyens on n pas de moins moy de
vrais moyens contre contre ces
propriétaires indélicats on va les
nommer c'est des marchands de sommeil
hein pour la plupart du cas et
alors le problème c'est c'est une fois
de plus on est sur des procédures
complexes très très longues pour la
copropriété et tout ça fait qu'à un
moment donné on a le sentiment alors
déjà nos concitoyens ont le sentiment
qu'on ne traite pas la difficulté voà
qu'on fait oui madame le dit très
justement qu'on qu'on fait mal les
choses mais en fait à partir du moment
où on n'a pas des textes on n' pas un
contentieux devant les juridictions sur
lequel on puisse s'appuyer
malheureusement on est on est
complètement démuni donc là aussi
peut-être quelques propositions et je
remets les choses au conditionnel hein
parce que bien évidemment je suis devant
vous avec beaucoup d'humilité dans nos
propositions doter peut-être les
inspecteur de salubrité ou les agents de
police municipale de pouvoir d'enquête
judiciaire en habitat indigne euh en
2000 en 2020 rappelons-nous les
inspecteurs de l'environnement se sont
vu attribuer des pouvoirs exceptionnels
et des pouvoirs élargis est-ce qu'on
peut s'appuyer là-dessus je pose la
question une fois de plus je sais que le
ministre de l'Intérieur souhaitait aussi
donner des pouvoirs supplémentaires aux
polices municipales puisque c'est
quelque chose qui nous parle à nous
aussi les maires est-ce que c'est le cas
et évidemment en lisant quand même votre
rapport nous avons aussi des des souvent
des euh des outils comme un GLTD ce
qu'on appelle un GLTT peut-être est-ce
que ce GLTD peut intervenir aussi pour
ma part j'en ai un qui est en cours à
mulouse où effectivement le logement le
traitement euh de je veux dire des des
des propriétaires ind indélicats fait
partie prenant de ce GLTD mais euh il
reste une fois de plus puisqu'on on peut
pas faire on peut pas avoir de GLTD sans
avoir aussi cet ingrédient en logement
mais ça reste une partie une fraction de
ce GLTD est-ce qu'il y aurait peut-être
moyen de d'amplifier les choses ou de
créer ce qu'on pourrait appeler un GLTD
spécifique au logement indigne voilà je
je pose les choses hein avec une fois de
plus je ne je n'ai pas d'affirmation
alors évidemment faciliter la mise en
application le GLTD c'est groupement
local de traitement de la
délinquence ah pardon je vous prie de
m'excuser je
jargonne oui non je suis d'accord
français voilà
l'acronymie voilà heureusement qu'on a
une présidente qui connaît bien les
choses oui c'est vrai j'aurais pu le
dire parce qu'on est on est on est
tellement passionné dans ce qu'on fait
nous les maires que qu'on jargonne à
longueur de
journée
voilà et effectivement la mise en
application de mesures notamment
peut-être celles qui sont relatives à la
saisie de l'eau en impayé en proposant
peut-être une substitution par les
collectivités en cas d'action d'inaction
du syndique parce qu'on voit très bien
aussi et je crois que Madame l'a relevé
tout à l'heure finalement l'inaction
l'inaction d'un syndique fait aussi que
les choses soient délayées dans le temps
et donc que les copropriétaires ou les
propriétaires indélicats ne soient pas
sanctionnés tout de suite c'est c'est
parfois aussi une façon d'éguisé de
d'avancer dans le temps et peut-être
aussi ben surtout d'ailleurs du dans le
cadre où l'immeuble est frappé d'une
procédure qui engage qui engage la
responsabilité parce que une fois de
plus plus le syndique a quand même une
responsabilité elle est engagée mais
elle n'est pas toujours partagée et elle
n'est pas toujours perçue en tant que
tel et peut-être aussi mettre en
cohérence les différents codes qui
existent je sais qu'il y a des efforts
qui ont été faits mais entre le code de
l'urbanisme et tous les codes que nous
connaissons aussi n'y aurait-il pas
moyen de de trouver une espèce de
cohérence en tout cas rendre les choses
peut-être plus fluide une fois de plus
et plus lisible voilà c'est c'est par là
que je terminerai mes propos et je vais
laisser peut-être à Mathieu la
conclusion si si madame la Présidente
est d'accord bien
s
pardon moi j'ai j'ai pas de conclusion
si ce n'est que vous dire que je suis
quand même très heureux parce qu'il y av
eu des
engagements du gouvernement du président
de la République de mettre ce sujet à
l'ordre du jour aujourd'hui on voit
qu'il y arrive c'était quand le ministre
clin nous a confié cette mission c'était
avec une perspective pour nourrir une
réflexion qui devait amener à ce projet
de loi on y est et et je pense
que dans dans le moment politique que
nous vivons c'est aussi bien d'avoir
finalement ces espaces un petit peu
voilà qui font consensus
transpartisan où on peut aussi entendre
la voix des maires des collectivités
parce que je veux vous redire que ce
travaill là aujourd'hui il est issu de
Michel moême mais on n'a pas du tout la
prétention d'avoir inventé le fil à
couper le beur quoi on on on répond à
des problématiques que tous les maires
de j'allis dire tous ceux qu'on a
rencontré avec toutes les couleurs
politiques se pose sont confrontés et
des fois s'arrache les cheveux parce
qu'il y a quand même rien de pire quand
on est maire élu local que le bon sens
commande d'agir et que on peut pas et
que c'est long et que on n arrive pas et
qu'à la fin parfois de manière immoral
on récompense les mauvaises
personnes la dernière proposition que
enfin qui qu Michel enfin je veux dire
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui quand on
débarque dans un logement on n pas le
droit de le visiter en même temps et au
au niveau du Code de l'Urbanisme et au
niveau du code du logement et donc on en
vient à donner des permis de loué pour
ceux qui l'ont activé à des logements
qui sont en infraction à l'urbanisme
majeur enfin je voilà quand on dit
unifier aussi un peu les polices de
l'habitat c'est tout ça derrière c'est
pour pouvoir être dans cette approche
pour les communes quand on Michel dis
simplification c'est aussi ce que
j'aiévoqué cette vision 360 on a les
compétences et il faut qu'on puisse
arriver à les exercer à l'exercer en
même
temps merci beaucoup madame le Maire
Monsieur le Maire pour cet exposé déjà
extrêmement complet précis et en tout
cas qui témoigne de la qualité de vos
travaux dans le cadre de cette mission
dont une partie on a compris figure dans
le texte du projet de loi donc j'ouvre
sans plus tarder euh la parole à
l'ensemble de nos commissaires
puisqu'ils sont très nombreux à cet
inscrit donc on va commencer par Amel
gaker Amel merci madame la présidente
Madame la Maire Monsieur le Maire merci
beaucoup et merci aussi pour l'approche
pragmatique que vous avez engagé vous
l'avez dit à plusieurs reprises sur le
sujet deux questions la première qui
porte sur la gouvernance notamment la
recherche d'une gouvernance efficace de
ce sujet à plusieurs reprises
association qui travaill sur le sujet
élu la Cour des comptes d'ailleurs aussi
à plusieurs reprises a relevé l'absence
de coordination de la politique de lutte
contre l'habitat indigne plus
précisément ils évoque le manque d'une
instance de concertation de pilotage au
sein de laquelle l'État les
collectivités territoriales pourraient
ensemble échanger travailler surtout sur
le sujet d'autant plus que les actions
sont nombreuses aujourd'hui on a pas mal
de dispositifs nationaux action cœur de
ville le npnru par exemple qui ont leurs
propres actions sur le sujet donc les
contours du du futur projets de loi ne
sont pas sont encore flous même si on
sait que nombre de vos propositions sont
sont sont actées est-ce que le texte
vous savez peut-être un petit peu plus
porte sur la gouvernance donc de cette
de la politique de lutte contre le
logement indigne et insalubre autour
d'une stratégie nationale qui serait
donc aujourd'hui formalisée et puis si
ce n'est pas le cas ou si c'est le cas
est-ce qu'il faut selon vous revoir le
fonctionnement de cette gouvernance que
que j'évoque et quelle forme
pourrait-elle prendre ça c'est la
première question et deuxème question
rapide qui porte sur l'habitat indigne
dans les territoires ruraux alors j'ai
entendu quand même vous l'avez dit à
plusieurs reprises que vous aviez bien
intégré que la problématique était
différente il n reste pas moins 88 % de
nos communes rurales en France 30 % de
la population française et le parc de
logement rural a quand même ses
particularités de grandes maisons
anciennes difficiles à chauffer parfois
des des des familles modestes des
problématiques donc de précarité
énergétique qui sont très présentes dans
le rural notamment diffus et de manière
plus concentrée au au sein des
centrebourgs avec aussi des locataires
qui trouvent refuge dans une partie du
locatif privé parfois dégradé donc dans
ces territoires la lutte contre
l'habitat indigne s'avère compliqué
parfois plus compliqué pour plusieurs
raisons la première parce que les élus
locaux ne sont pas forcément informés ça
c'est la première chose et puis la
deuxième aussi parce que il manque des
moyens un maillage en fait d'acteur et
qui et puis les politiques en fait un
public qui ne couvrent pas suffisamment
en fait ces ces territoires donc bref un
vrai problème je va le résumer comme ça
de repérage parce que vous le savez dans
la chaîne que vous évoquez repérer en
fait c'est ces logements indignes et
c'est un vrai cercle vicieux pourquoi
parce que défaut de repérage ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire défaut d'acteur
public pour pouvoir agir sur le sujet et
donc par conséquent des moyens d'action
aujourd'hui insuffisants alors quelles
sont vos propositions son sur le sujet
qui est encore une fois un sujet qui est
très prignant sur sur tous les
territoires merci beaucoup merci Amel on
va prendre des questions TR par TR donc
Franck Menonville et Vivian Artigalas et
ensuite on Dona la parole à oui merci
madame la présidente madame le Maire
Monsieur le Maire mais déjà vous
féliciter pour la qualité de de ce
rapport qui est
vraiment pragmatique qui qui répond
aussi aux réalités que nous vivons tous
dans nos territoires territoires urbains
territoires ruraux moi je voudrais
revenir sur un point qui me semble
absolument essentiel de votre rapport
c'est le lien à la propriété notamment
l'expropriation ou ou la préemption
parce que c'est absolument infernal ce
que nous vivons dans dans dans nos
territoires et y compris là bien
évidemment on focalise souvent sur les
les territoires urbains mais même dans
les territoires ruraux il y a des des
biens vacants qui se dégradent il y a
des des des des logement et ma question
porte aussi sur les biens vacants parce
qu'on parle de de logement euh euh euh
de dégradé insalubre mais il y a aussi
dans les communes des logements vacants
qui font régner des des risques de de
voisinage et aujourd'hui moi je suis on
on est tous confrontés à cela moi
j'étais confronté à barleduc par exemple
sur un dossier concret plus près de 30
ans pour pour aboutir et finalement les
les procédures successives non ont
permis d'aboutir à l'amiable mais c'est
même pas la procédure juridique qui a
permis au dossier d'aboutir je pense que
c'est vraiment un sujet absolument
absolument essentiel il y a eu beaucoup
d'initiatives au Sénat je salue les
collègues du RDC je crois que c'était le
le président du RDSE Jean-Claude requier
qui avait porté une une PPL pour
faciliter cela mais on voit que ça n'a
jamais été vraiment suffisamment opérant
et la question donc que je souhaite vous
poser c'est comment définissez-vous les
le contour de de C de ces nouvelles
possibilité notamment sur est-ce que
vous y voyez aussi le l'élargissement à
des à des biens vacants qui se dégradent
et et surtout est-ce que c'est
conditionné aussi à des documents
d'urbanisme à des à des périmètres ou
est-ce que c'est vraiment la
situation réelle de de l'habitat ou de
l'immobilier qui déterminera la les les
moyens et les conditions d'action merci
Franck Vivien
Artigalas merci madame la Présidente
merci Madame le Maire Monsieur le Maire
de VO aussi de votre rapport parce que
je crois qu'il est très attendu sur les
territoires et cette loi elle est très
attendue aussi pour faciliter l'action à
ce sujet moi j'ai pu voir effectivement
dans dans quelques quelques déplacements
à Grini et à voix envelin combien cette
question était prégante et comment cet
immobilisme qu'on qu'on a et cette
longueur dans le temps on a évoqué je
l'ai vu à Grini la longueur sur une
copropriété dégradée le temps qu'on
arrive à faire à trouver une solution
combien bien aussi c'est par par vous
l'avez dit des syndicats aussi qui ne de
copropriété qui ne sont pas très
efficaces ou même des administrateurs
judiciaires qui ne sont pas efficaces
comment on arrive finalement à des
conséquences dramatiques dans certains
dans certains territoires je vous
remercie aussi d'avoir parlé de la
ruralité et des outres mèes et je
rejoins donc les questions de d'Amel sur
les questions de de la ruralité
effectivement ce sujet sétend sur tous
les territoires il n'y a pas que les
voilà moi j'avais de questions sur le le
reste à charge des collectivités vous
aviez bien montré que entre la question
du relogement et la question de de
l'évaluation qui est là des immeubles
dégradés combien à un moment donné ce
reste à charge pour les collectivités
peuvent être tellement important qu'il
peut amener finalement de l'inaction ou
du du fait qu' on narrive pas à trouver
les moyens et les finances des
collectivités actuellement m'incite à
dire que ce problème peut s'aggraver
donc vous faites des propositions dans
ce sens-là mais est-ce que vous pouvez
être un petit peu plus précis sur ce ce
aider à ce rest à charge pour la
question du relogement qui me paraît une
des plus importantes aussi sur la
question du portage du foncier le rôle
est-ce que vous pensez que les
établissements publics fonciers peuvent
avoir un rôle dans ce sur ce sujet et
puis moi je me pose la question aussi
des euh des bailleurs des organismes HLM
en tant que syndque public parce que
est-ce que c'est vraiment J cieux sur
des questions de de copropriété
complètement privé voilà puisque voilà
ils vont intervenir sur des copropriétés
privé mais est-ce que ça peut pas
entraîner après obligatoirement aller
vers des logements sociaux que vous ne
souhaitez pas peut-être sur certains
territoires voilà mes trois questions
merci merci donc je vais vous laisser
répondre à ces trois premières questions
je ne sais pas qui veut commencer madame
le Maire je va laisserai Mathieu plutôt
sur la question de la loi vivient
puisque c'est un peu sa spécialité la
question de la gouvernance posée par
Madame évidemment elle est cruciale
cette cette cette question de
gouvernance alors c'est vrai qu'il
existe déjà des dispositif à l'heure
actuelle et en ce qui me concerne en
tout cas notre vision des choses c'est
de dire que cette gouvernance ne peut
que s'exercer pour être efficace au
niveau local voilà parce qu'on sait très
bien que si on se détache du niveau
local on perd en efficacité on l'a dit
des procédures longues et tout le reste
la question est aussi il existe déjà le
plan des appartemental pour le le le
logement des personnes défavorisées
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
une une première pierre posée qu'il faut
cranter qu'il faut améliorer je pose la
question aussi puisque je n'en ai pas la
réponse à ce stade-là alors la question
de la ruralité évidemment on l'a vu et
il faut savoir que nous les maires de
plus grandes villes nous avons une
chance inouï c'est que nous sommes
organisés avec nos services dans la
conduite d'un certain nombre de choses
par contre il y a deux éléments qui
reviennent en permanence quand on parle
avec les maires qui sont en ruralité
c'est la question d'une part de
l'ingénierie voilà et celle-là elle est
elle est elle est cruciale il va falloir
vraiment qu'on ait des dispositifs pour
améliorer cette question d'ingénierie
parce que aucun maire et même nous dans
les dans les plus grandes villes ou dans
les dans les dans les métropole nous
n'avons assez de moyens RH pour
compenser cette ingénierie ça n'est pas
possible pour l'instant nous ne sommes
pas outillés à forciorie les les
communes en ruralité et qui qui souvent
agissent avec des moyens qui n'en sont
pas voilà qui ne peuvent pas agir et
même si peut-être quoi que je mets quand
même un bémol on a toujours l'impression
que c'est dans les grandes villes ou
dans les grandes métropoles évidemment
le volume à traiter est plus important
mais si on ramène ça au nombre de
personnes en capacité de le traiter en
ruralité ils ont un travail titanesque à
faire là-dessus et ils ne sont pas pas
outiers ils ne sont pas équipés pour ça
et
une une des choses et le ministre l'a
exprimé il a dit c'est une grande cause
nationale et à ce titrelà bien sûr il va
falloir un moment donné que nous
fassions appel à la solidarité nationale
et on ne on ne réussira pas à régler ce
problème parce que cette ingénierie elle
est cruciale comme la question des
enquêtes nous n'avons pas suffisamment
de RH dans nos collectivités pour mener
les enquêtes administra
juridique jusqu'à un certain point pour
amener et pour porter ce dossier devant
les juridictions c'est un souci
également une fois dans dans dans ce
souci de pragmatisme voilà ce que je je
pourrais en dire alors oui il existe des
des des plans
départementaux je pense qu'il faut je
pense qu'il faut revoir les choses j'ai
pas dit que ça n'a pas fait son effet je
ne suis pas en train de dire que c'est
mal fait je dis simplement que ça n'est
plus suffisant au vu des volumes qu'il
faut traiter actuellement voilà ce que
je pourrais dire j'ai peut-être oublié
quelque chose madame dans dans vos
propos j'ai essayé de noter en même
temps et euh mais je pense que la
question de la ruralité doit vraiment
vraiment être traité aussi parce que les
les gens moi j'ai j'ai rencontré des
mères qui sont complètement désespérés
qui sont démunis parce qu'ils n'arrivent
pas à traiter les choses et même quand
un maire en ruralité a un immeuble avec
six appartement à traiter ou six
logements à traiter ça devient quelque
chose d'infernal voilà
monsieur merci madame la
présidente madame la sénatrice gaker
vous
posez enfin une très bonne question qui
pour le coup ne trouvera pas de réponse
dans le projet de loi qui est là mais ce
que nous a annoncé le ministre c'est que
c'était l'objet un des
objets grande loi décentralisation du
logement mais je vous je vous je vous je
je vous donne mon niveau d'information
merci pour votre réponse claire
voilà donc néanmoins je vous donner du
coup maintenant que je donné mon état
d'information mon avis si vous me le
permettez nous avons besoin
d'acter que il faut qu'il y ait un
pilote sur la question de la lutte
contre l'habite indigne et que ce pilote
c'est pas le même
partout il faut avoir une capacité
d'adaptation en fonction de nos réalités
locales qui vont pas être les même d'un
département à un autre d'une ville à une
autre d'une métropole à une autre qui
vont parfois dépendre de réalités
physique et géographique qui vont
parfois défendre de paralysies
politiques qui peuvent exister parce que
cachons pas ça existe aussi hein des des
dysfonctionnements ville métropole et
cetera ou ville établissement public et
cetera et cetera donc moi je pense qu'il
faut qu'on arrive à avoir une situation
de souplesse peut-être par la signature
euh avec un état stratège qui fixe des
objectifs et après peut-être une logique
de contrat pour activer les choses s'il
y a une certitude que j'ai c'est que par
contre il faut réunir l'exercice des
compétences c'estàd que la personne qui
a les compétences elle doit les avoir
toutes en la personne morale le niveau
d'action si on dit que c'est un
établissement public de coopération
intercommunale très bien mais il faut
arrêter la segmentation entre l'État qui
fait l'insalubrité les communes qui font
le péril euh et et voilà et tout ce que
j'ai dit il faut donner les moyens
d'agir ensemble ça c'est vraiment pour
moi extrêmement important pour le coup
je vous fais part de ma modeste
expérience c'est ce que nous avons fait
c'est ce que nous faisons c'est ce que
nous avons fait à Saint-Denis et cette
action 360 bah déjà par exemple sur la
question des enquêtes pénales c'est
simple aujourd'hui la moitié des enquête
pénale du parquet de bobini viennent de
la ville de Saint-Denis il y a 120
enquêtes ouvertes il y en a 60 qui
viennent de Saint-Denis c'est c'est
aussi parce qu'on s'est mieux organisé
et que aujourd'hui on a ce savoir-faire
qu'on a construit qui est reconnu les
gens viennent nous voir pour voir
comment on s'est organisé
justement surerci politique alors c'est
un coup hein parce que aujourd'hui la
ville de saint-n pour ex la compétence
de l'État dans cette loi qui est là de
1983 elle est compensé à hauteur de
700000 € et le coût pour exercer la
compétence de l'État RH et cetera et
cetera c'est 2ion3 voilà donc c'est un
choix politique que moi j'ai fait parce
que c'est quand même 5000 habit 5000
logements qui sont autour de l'habitat
indigne euh donc vous voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est 20 % de
l'habitat privé enfin on est dans des
situation colossal et il y a des moments
bah il faut y aller et puis qu'on a pas
envie d'avoir des drames non plus
évidemment euh voilà
mais
mais honnêtement moi j'ai j'ai j'ai par
exemple dans nous on a une coopération
avec le PT et c'est vrai qu'on a eu
plutôt une tendance à déléguer à notre
établissement public intercommunale et
dans cette férence là on a plutôt fait
redescendre euh la compétence au niveau
de la mairie pour être aussi au plus
près du terrain en lien avec les polices
municipales en lien avec les acteurs qui
signalent sur le terrain donc en fait je
pense qu'il faut que chacun puisse
construire sa solution mais en unifiant
les politiques en tout cas c'est moi
c'est c'est c'est ma réponse sur la
question de la gouvernance et avec un
état qui est stratège mais honnêtement
enfin je veux dire qui reste stratège
non mais je je suis désolé de dire en
ces termes là
mais mais moi c'est c'est on peut pas
passer des heures à se battre à faire
des copiles pour espérer que la RS
vienne faire un contrôle quoi enfin je
ve dire c'est quand on sait qu'il a
besoin qu'il est là qu'on passe devant
tous les jour il faut que le maire il
puisse le décider euh voilà
euh excusez-moi donc
monsieur le sénateur Menonville je suis
désolé j'ai oublié mes lunettes donc je
suis dans un une problématique très
opérationnelle et c'est pas mon écriture
donc sur la question la
question je vais commencer par la
question des logements vacans je l'ai
compris aussi comme la question des bi
100 m si vous me permettez cette cette
problématique on l'a identifié
honnêtement on n pas écrit on n pas
écrit aujourd'hui la solution parce que
là on est vraiment dans un très
spécifique ou il faut que le
gouvernement permettre d'accélérer nous
c'est comme ça on l'a dit qu'on l'a
écrit les procédures de bien s' MRE qui
aujourd'hui peuvent prendre des années
et des années délai qui se surrajoute à
tous les délais que j'ai évoqué
préalablement
ouais mais donc euh donc là-dessus
beaucoup de mères ont été confrontés à
ça c'est une problématique dans la
ruralité qui moi qui m monté chez
beaucoup de mères on est allé aussi
c'était à l'aval de
devant avec la MF l'assemblée des des
communes rurales et cette problématique
elle est remontée extrêmement fortement
nous on l'a signalé mais on n pas eu à
notre niveau la compétence technique
pour pour écrire finalement ses
spécificités ceci étant dit quand on
parle pas de bien s' mettre toutes les
dispositions qu'on propose demain elles
s'appliqueront au l vacan il y a pas de
sujet c'est la question de l'immeuble
qui est concerné on n'est pas comme dans
le permis de louer finalement ou
finalement c'est question du du
locataire en tant que tel qui peut
déclencher une action non mais voilà
donc même pour des logements inoccupés
il peut avoir des menaces défondément et
il y a des questions d'insalubrité
également et donc ça c'est les pouvoirs
du police du maire là-dessus donc ça
concerne les logement vacan et le le le
droit qu'on écrit bah il sera le même
pour une logement dans lequel il y a un
habitant ind
qu il y en a 100 voilà et donc avancer
la chaîne entre entre guillemets ça sera
profitable pour tout le monde commune
urbaine ou commune rurale après il y a
des questions de d'ingéniéie qu'on
évoqué précédemment qui sont cruciales
et qui sont nécessaires en zone rurale
moi j'ai la faiblesse de croire que pour
le coup les communutés de communes sont
le bon
échelon dans des grandes villes j'ai
plutôt tendance à penser que c'est au
niveau de la municipalité parce qu'il
faut qu'on arrive à combiner finalement
ce C cette besoin de proximité de
repérage et de et de connexion en
particulier avec les pouvoirs de police
notamment police municipale quand elles
existent et en même temps une ingénierie
suffisamment forte rodée voilà euh c'est
un nit aujourd'hui dans notre direction
de l'habitat durable on a une
quarantaine de personnes et on va monter
entre 40 et 50 notamment lorsque l'on
fusionnera avec la ville d'à côté au 1er
janvier 2025 la ville de pierrefit mais
c'est un autre sujet donct je vous
parlerai peut-être une autre fois mais
pas aujourd'hui
euh madame la sénatrice Artigalas euh
le sur
le sur le foncier d'abord le foncier
vous avez parfaitement raison on a une
proposition d'ailleurs dans le rapport
jeis passé un peu vite dessus
excusez-moi mais on a besoin pour le
coup on parlait on parlait d'État
stratège par sil y a bien un sujet sur
lequel les maires attendent d'être
accompagnés par la puissance publique
étatique c'est la question de la
maîtrise du
foncier aujourd'hui on n pas de
stratégie foncière nationale je suis de
dire dans ces termes là on a des outils
qui existent dans presque toutes les
régions des EPF
régionaux qui sont suffisamment soclclés
pour être costaud financièrement mais
Don aujourd'hui les missions ne sont pas
celle ni de faire de la réserve foncière
de très long terme pour préparer des
grands projets d'avenir ni d'intervenir
finalement là où les collectivités ne
savent pas faire et donc de nous
accompagner sur la maîtrise petit à
petit de copro et cetera et cetera ça ce
sont les communes les les EPCI qui le
font en direct ou via leurs outil
d'aménagement aménageurs public comme la
soreka par exemple ou en Île-de-France
ou SPEN à Marseille et cetera et cetera
mais cette cette volume MRIE financière
sur le portage foncier elle est
cruciale moi je milite activement pour
pas qu'on crée un machin de plus mais
pour que par contre on donne sur la
question de l'habitat indigne une
mission aux EPF ça demande de clarifier
un certain nombre de choses sur la les
chaînes de responsabilité notamment
pénal parce que sur problème quand on va
l'acquérir de d'habitat indigne il faut
pas non plus que les EPF deviennent des
marchands de sommeil entre guillemets
vous voyez ce que je veux dire il y a
des solutions mais il y a des solutions
euh moi j'en ai on les a rencontré he
des représentants de d'établissement
public foncier moi je pense qu'on
pourrait imaginer que les EPF viennent à
partir du moment où il y a le
déclenchement aussi d'outils de
puissance publique qui permettent et on
fait le lien avec tout ce qu'on a dit
avant de s'occuper des occupants de les
sortir de les mettre à côté mais que en
tout cas financièrement ils puissent
porter si on veut accélérer c'est
toujours pareil quand dans une ville
comme saintis c'est 5000 logements
d'habitat indignne honnêtement c'est pas
une solution qu'il faut mobiliser c'est
10 15 cumulative avec en particulier
aussi les acteurs privés on n' pas
beaucoup parlé aujourd'hui mais on a
besoin des acteurs privé que les grandes
foncières elles se mettent sur ce
marché-là qu'elles se mobilisent que
elles-même elles trouent un intérêt
économique de ce point de vue-là la
question la pérénisation du de Normandie
là qui est prévu dans le PLF c'est une
très bonne chose mais disons-le notre
recommandation avec Michel c'est non
seulement une pérénisation mais aussi
une extension notamment pour qu'il
puisse euh euh couvrir bah les grandes
métropoles là où il y en a quand même
malgré tout le plus en volume et donc
finalement de créer suffisamment
d'intéressement volumétriquement
financier pour qu'on puisse euh avoir
ces foncières qui se spécialisent un
petit peu sur euh sur sur le sujet euh
on on dit qu'on a besoin de construire
des milliers et des milliers de
logements enfin là on a des milliers et
des milliers de lement qui sont devant
nous à coout carbone quasiment zéro
parce qu'on parle de rénovation au
contraire d'amélior
à chaque fois et qui pourrait très bien
recevoir des occupants dans de bonnes
conditions et que aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas le cas un mot sur la question du
syndque pour qu'on se comprenne bien sur
ce qu'on a
écrit on a beaucoup hésité à mettre
cette proposition parce qu'en fait on
tourne tous un peu autour du sujet
syndque on voit qu'il y a un problème
pour donc on a mis la dans la loi il y a
des obligations d'information qui qui
portent sur les syndques pour clarifier
leur rôle leur mission mais on on on a
constaté avec Michel qu'il y avait un
problème spécifique sur finalement cet
ingénierie privée des
copropriétaires pour accompagner soit le
redressement de leur immeuble soit le
bonne
entretien aujourd'hui on a deux choses
qui existent et qui ni l'une ni l'autre
ne sont satisfaisantes on a ce qu'on
appelle des administrations judiciaires
qui quand on en arrive à ce stade bon et
ben en fait ça ne marche pas souvent j
rarement voilà sauf quand ça marchera
quand il va y avoir un accompagnement
extrêmement fort de la puissance
publique à côté de l'administration
judiciaire type clich s bois avec une
orcodeen et cetera et cetera et cetera
mais c'est pas du coup l'administration
judiciaire seule qui
marche quand il y a la carence
concrètement et qu'on donne à
administration judiciaire bon
honnêtement on n pas à faire compris des
experts ingénieur de l'immobilier qui
vont trouver des solutions magiques et
c'est bien normal donc à côté de ça on a
une autre disposition et on a nous dans
des villes je penseais à épiner sur
scène avec cette grande copropriété en
IGH voilà la tour
bellisque qui dont la dégradation s'est
accélérée à partir du moment où elle est
passée en administration
judiciaire voilà et qui a fini par être
évacué il y a un an et demi dans des
conditions enfin bref très compliquées
il y a un autre dispositif qui existe
qui s'pp le syndique de redressement qui
a un statut mais aujourd'hui il y a un
problème majeur d'équilibrage économique
c'estàdire pour vous le dire très
concrètement aujourd'hui les indiges ne
gagnent pas d'argent ils en perdent à
s'occuper de à s'occuper bien de
copropriétés dégradé soit c'est une
petite part de leur portefeuille et on
dire ils vont équilibrer avec des
affaires qui marchent très bien qui vont
finalement servir à compenser ces
affaires qui marchent moyen parce que
que très prosaïquement ça prend beaucoup
plus de temps mais ça prend des heures
et des heures et donc tout ça à la fin
ne se et avec des copropriétaires qui
bien souvent sont ceux qui n'ont pas le
plus d'argent pour payer des charges
élevées et donc en fait voilà donc moi
mon opinion c'est que en tout cas quand
on est dans une action type op pas il
faut réussir à cadrer les choses pour
pas que ça deviennne n'importe quoi mais
le but c'est pas de faire basculer
ces ces copropriétés dans le domaine
public par contre c'est de créer un
outil que nous on a dit qui pourrait
s'appeler syndique d'intérêt général qui
pourrait être opéré par les les les
offices dans le cadre d'une politique de
diversification de leur offrees mais
peut-être d'autres aussi acteurs qui
pourraient se spécialiser dessus mais où
finalement l'intérêt pourquoi est-ce
qu'on dit les offices c'est que il faut
réussir à le sortir du champ
concurrentiel pour qu'on puisse le
subventionner parce que disons-le à ce
sujet c'est une ingénierie qui doit être
subventionnée sinon elle ne sera jamais
rentable mais c'est notre intérêt parce
que si on la subventionne assez tôt
c'est autant d'immeubles qu'on aura pas
en recyclage plus tard et au final les
quelques milliers d'euros de
subvention de fonctionnement qu'on aura
donné à la copropriété ils seront rien
du tout par rapport au coût de
résorption auquel on aura échappé mais
aujourd'hui le problème c'est qu'on peut
pas donner une subvention à un syndicque
privé classique qui est dans le champ
concurrentiel voilà et donc c'est
là-dessus qu'on a réfléchi et ce qu'on a
demandé en fait parce qu'on est quand
même malgré tout je vais très honnête
avec vous pas complètement sûr que ça
marche de nos réponses donc on a demandé
à pouvoir faire une
expérimentation sur ce
sujet du coup c'est pas du domaine
législatif donc ça ne se retrouve pas
dans la loi mais normalement il y a un
accord pour que un décret permette de
tester cette
expérimentation merci beaucoup donc on
va continuer je demande à nos
commissaires d'être assez concis dans
leurs questions parce qu'il y en a
encore beaucoup donc Serge meriloup
Antoinette Gul et Yve bleuven Serge
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
et et Monsieur le Maire de votre rapport
ma question porte sur la proposition
numéro 20 qui est pour moi le point de
départ du traitement de l'habitat
indigne c'est-à-dire le
recensement et la localisation de de et
le signalement de ce TR de cet habitant
indigne vous proposez des solutions
numéri notamment d'améliorer les outils
numériques existants et notamment les
est
connecté donc c'est qu'il y a
probablement des difficultés
actuellement sur ces outils numériques à
mon sens il correspondent bien sur de
l'habitat collectif de grande dimension
et donc ma question
rejointà la question d'Amel
gaker il est beaucoup plus difficile
dans de l'habitat diffus en zone rurale
voire du petit du petit collectif de
terminer et de d'isoler cet habitant
indigne de de le
connaître et il me semble qu'il manque
dans ce rapport
probablement toute la partie physique on
a plus aujourd'hui dans nos communes
dans nos territoires des personnes
physique des interlocuteurs que l'on
peut rencontrer pour signaler cet
habitant indigne et puis je m'aperçois
que la la l'habitat indigne il est vécu
par les les victimes de
façon j'allais dire honteuse presque
c'està-dire qu'on n'ose pas
recevoir j'ai été comme beaucoup d'entre
vous maèr et et le premier signal c'est
quand un un habitant vous dit j'ai
besoin de vous voir mais je passe te
voir non je viendrai à la mairie déjà
vous voyez que cette personneel elle a
du mal à elle a du mal à à en parler
elle est vécu presque de façon honteuse
donc ma question c'est on a besoin de
remettre de l'humain derri derrière
cette détection de l'habitat indigne de
remettre de l'humanité pour ce qui est
un besoin fondamental de nos
concitoyen merci Serge Antoinette Gul
oui oui bonjour à toutes et tous merci à
vous deux particulièrement j'avoue
qu'avoir un rapport qui est fait par des
maires et bien c'est rassurant parce
qu'on sent la pertinence des
propositions moi je voudrais vous
interroger sur un point qui
est j'allais dire presque un point
annexe mais en tout cas qui qui est
malgré tout important c'est comment
s'assurer en fait que toutes ces
procédures qui vont dans le sens de
l'intérêt général ne sont pas détournés
et en particulier ne sont pas détournés
à l'encontre de petits propriétaires qui
sont pas des propriétaires aisés qui se
trouent dans des copropriétés qui ne
sont pas encore dégradés mais qui vont
l'être très prochainement parce que vous
avez des syndques malintentionné et que
la profession de syndique est mal
contrôlée mal encadrée que fait-on
contre ça mais mais parce que aussi la
solution que vous évoquiez
d'administrateur provisoire et bien ne
fonctionne quasiment jamais enfin elle
ne fonctionne jamais elle n'aboutit
jamais à une résolution du problème elle
aboutit effectivement enfin souvent à
l'expropriation et quelquefois quand
tous ces intérêt malinttentionné se lit
et bien en réalité ce sont des habitants
et des habitants souvent pas très aisés
puisque ceux qui accèdent à la propriété
dans ce type d'habitat qui peut être qui
qui peut commencer à se déclarer ben
effectivement ce sont pas les plus
aisés de la population donc comment
fait-on aussi pour protéger des abus que
peut générer ce type de procédure et par
ailleurs je suis tout à fait d'accord
sur le caractère
essentiel du rapport et des des actions
qui sont proposées voilà merci Yve
levenen madame la Présidente merci à
vous deux pour l'excellent travail que
vous vous avez réalisé et ses
propositions je voudrais vous soumettre
une idée complémentaire puisque on l'a
abordé dans les différents outils euh on
est tous ici souvent des anciens maires
on a connu les outils qu'on a eu entre
les mains et je voudrais revenir sur les
CCAS les CCAS quand on regarde dans leur
mission ils s'occupent beaucoup de
logement ils s'occupent de logement
indigne ils s'occupe à faire du repérage
sur l'allogement indigne il s'occupe à à
à à accompagner malheureusement les les
résidents de ces logements qui sont
souvent en grande précarité par contre
les CCS n'ont pas du tout les outils
d'accompagnement sur la rénovation sur
parce qu'on s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui
dans nos communes bon nombre de CCS sont
propriétaires de patrimoine que ce
patrimoine a besoin d'être rénové mais
ces CCS peuvent a être parfaitement les
légataires de patrimoine d'habitat
indigne souvent sur des petites
opérations on parle beaucoup des
bailleurs sociaux sur des grandes
opérations mais quand il faut faire du
cou humain ou des petites opérations en
milieu rural sans doute que le CCAS a un
rôle à jouer et par contre les CCS ne
sont pas éligibles aux aide à la pierre
ne sont pas éligibles à Dr ne sont pas
éligibles à la décile j'ai fait passer
un amendement il y a 15 jours sur la loi
de finan 2024 il a été adopté dans une
mission qui a été rejetée mais n'empêche
que c'est pas normal qu'on ne puisse pas
avoir
dans une filiale à 100 % d'une commune
un outil comme le CCS capable de venir
parmi les multiples outils qu'on a à
disposition nous accompagner dans ce
genre de de politique en tout cas moi je
suis persuadé qu'il y a pas besoin de
Grand- choses mais avec cccs et puis
sans doute mener une réflexion sur la
capacité à récupérer tous ces biens avec
Maître parce que il y a les biens sans
matrre mais il y a aussi les biens avec
maîtrre avec des gens qu'on accompagne
sur de la fin de vie sur des situations
de précarité importante et qui sont
prêts à vous signer le leg et là-dessus
je pense que le CCS est un très bel
outil merci merci donc je vous laisse
répondre madame monsieur le Maire vous
commencez ou madame le Maire pe très
rapidement non mais sur finalement moi
je trouve quelque chose de très commun
dans dans ce que vous venez de dire
monsur le sénateur levenen et et
monsieur le sénateur merilou euh en fait
et c'est pour cette raisonlà que moi je
vous ai dit qu'on a essayer de de
finalement de recentraliser au niveau de
la mairie nos outils c'est pour cette
question de la
proximité c'est pour cette question de
la proximité parce que justement le CCAS
a un rôle d'alerte majeur parce qu'il
voit les publics en difficultés et que
lui il a cette capacité à se brancher
avec ses collègues qui sont dans le
bureau d'à côté qui eux vont être dans
l'habit indigne voir à informer sur les
droits voire à renvoyer sur une
permanence de la DAL je l'ai dit he il y
a tout un bloc sur une meilleure
information
des propriétaires mais aussi des
locataires sur leur droits sur leur
capacitéagir et ça c'est prévu dans le
dans le projet de loi le gouvernement a
une volonté de pouvoir y compris
continuer à développer des outils
numériques
existants hisologe
[Musique]
aujourd'hui honnêtement je pense que ces
outils sont utiles je suis pas sûr qu'il
le soit complètement sur la lutte contre
l'habitat
indigne c'estd que euh sur sur la
question de l'état du logement plus
globalement sur la question de
problématique comme la rénovation
énergétique on on voit bien qu'on on
peut avoir des tiles de référencement
mais qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui en fait
est référencé de beaucoup dans histologe
c'est aussi beaucoup de de choses qui
sont de ressort du tracas du quotidien
et donc il faut faire attention aussi à
pas c'est ce que moi c'est toute la
discussion qu'on a eu et c'est le pour
et le contre des outils numériques qui
facilit les choses mais si c'est pour
qu'en fait on on comment dire on
embolise nos services avec un filet qui
est trop grand euh où il do aller faire
une visite de contrôle dès qu'il y a une
moisis sûr euh parce que quelqu'un n'a
pas aéré euh vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est que ça ne marche pas non plus
donc
ou qu' a un dégât d' mineur qui relève
pour le coup strictement d'une approche
privée privée quoi
euh voilà donc à l'évidence il y a un
rôle pour les outils numérique on en a
un la question c'est comment on arrive à
le spécifier finalement mieux autour de
l'habit indigne parce que aujourd'hui il
est pas assez spécifique c'esté un petit
peu ça aussi l'idée de dire on peut pas
voir l'outil qu'on a aujourd'hui comme
un outil euh en tout cas majeur de lutte
contre l'habit euh
euh mais donc moi je partage
complètement ce qui est dit sur le
guichet unique en fait c'est là on est
dans de l'humain euh
physique même si on a du numérique un
téléphone de toute façon ça passe par un
rendez-vous ça passe par un
accompagnement et parce que bizarrement
rarement la personne a un seul problème
celui de l'habit indigne c'estun celle
qui l'habite ind ligne elle là aussi
généralement tout le package qui va avec
euh évidemment et et que c'est aussi en
en en en lui proposant cet
accompagnement global qu'on arrive à
l'amener y compris sur la résorption du
su dehabit indi euh madame la sénatrice
Gul euh c'est c'est c'est je suis très
content que vous me posz cette question
finalement des gardesfous euh euh
alors euh je me permets de dire que sur
votre problématique euh en fait c'est
aujourd'hui le sujet sur exactement ce
que vous évoquez disons-le des accords
entre des propriétaires verreux et des
syndicques malintentionné qui vont un
peu comme il y en a qui jouent à la
Bourse madame la Présidente vous savez à
la baisse voilà non pas vous mais ça
existe et qui gagne de l'argent et bien
là il y a des gens qui gagnent de
l'argent beaucoup d'argent en organisant
la chute des copropriétés de manière
très simple il se débrouille pour
finalement récupérer via le syndi ou des
amis une forme de majorité dans la
copropriété ils organisent sa
dégradation en louant à 15 personnes des
tout petits logements avec des
conditions et cetera en investissant
plus rien donc là évidemment plus
personne veut acheter donc il rachète
les autres logement à ville prix ils
font tourner la machine passez-moi
l'expression bien souvent y compris de
manière frauduleuse par le paiement de
loyers en liquide et cetera et cetera et
à la fin de la fin de la fin ils se font
racheter par la publ ou par un promoteur
et finalement comme ça on gagne sur tous
les tableaux investissement minimum
rendement maximal en fonctionnement et à
la fin avec une surprime donc ce schéma
là que je vous décris moi je l'ai vécu à
Saint-Denis dans un immeuble boulevard
Ornano que d'ailleurs président dans la
circonscription du député coqurel très
précise on a eu ce schéma là qui a été
organisé et et pas qu'une fois ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est quand même
aussi l'exception non mais mais je je
enfin il faut se le dire c'est pas non
plus le le lot commun quand il y a ce
niveau de malveillance de pilotage et
cetera heureusement que c'est pas comme
ça partout et que c'est pas de ça besoin
mais j'allais dire quand bien même les
outils qu'on propose il propose ça parce
que là les dérives que vous pointez
c'est pas c'est pas les dérives qu'on va
risquer avec avec les nouveaux outils
parce que finalement quand on exproprie
quelqu'un plusôt quand il y a plus de
solution on protège et on protège le
petit propriétaire parce que vous savez
quand on l'exproprie en loi Vivien à la
fin qu'est-ce qui est là dans la poche
le petit propriétaire pas grand-chose la
collectivité plus grand-chose non plus
parce que les cûpts de démolition de
dépollution de tout ça vont être
colossaux et donc au final on va aussi
perdre beaucoup d'argent en fait c'est
perdant perdant quand on laisse la
dégradation aller jusqu'au bout c'est
assez cohérent hein quand on laisse un
truc se dégrader bah il perde sa valeur
pour tout le monde Infiné euh tandis que
si on intervient plutôt soit par le
biais euh d'une intervention privée avec
des financements qu'on évoqué tout à
l'heure soit par le B d'intervention
publique là y compris on indemnise le
petit propriétaire à la une valeur plus
réelle plus juste euh que enfin parce
que son logement il vaut à ce moment là
15 ans plus tôt plus d'argent que 15 ans
plus tard et pour le coup on peut aussi
stopper quand on voit des phénomènes de
malveillance comme ça avec des gens qui
sont pris au piège parce que la
collectivité elle peut acheter à un prix
juste là où si on a des verreux qui ont
organisé la dégradation et ben eux ils
vont racheter à ville prix voilà donc au
contraire je pense que ce qu'on propose
permet de mieux lutter même si je n'ai
pas la prétention de dire qu'on va
empêcher les délinquants de ce pays
parce que il y aura toujours des gens
qui préféreront être à côté des lois que
dedans madame le Maire oui merci Madame
la président peut-être juste revenir si
vous m'y autorisez sur le reste à charge
ça a été dit tout à l'heure et on a pas
traité donc le reste à charge est
vraiment quelque chose de très imp
important on le rappelle souvent
malheureusement quand on est face à des
copropriétaires et des des marchands de
sommeil on a face à un public fragiles
des gens modestes et donc ça a été dit
tout à l'heure et là une fois de plus il
va falloir que l'État puisse être à nos
côtés pour pouvoir justement financer
préfinancer ces travaux qui qui pour moi
est essentiel à partir du moment où on
fait le constat qu' a eu des
défaillances sur des travaux qu'on n pas
en capacité de les les financer ou de
trouver quelque chose qui permettre de
le financer je crois qu'on est déjà face
à un échec voilà et comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure ces personnes on le voit
bien dans dans le traitement journalier
ces personnes échappent complètement au
système bancaire traditionnel donc ces
personnesl ne peuvent pas solliciter un
prêt parce qu'elles ne sont pas en
capacité en capacité financière de
rembourser donc je présente je vous
présente le sujet faut-il créer un fond
spécial pour ça faut-il que l'État
puisse effectivement octroyer des prêts
différencié différent du système normal
voilà la question se pose mais ça me
semblait important de pouvoir traiter
cette question de reste à charge alors
juste rapidement et je laisserai
peut-être mon premier adjoint vous vous
répondre aussi à un bout de la question
la question du CCAS monsieur
effectivement on est tous président de
CCAS aussi et je crois que une fois de
plus comme l'a dit Mathieu tout à
l'heure et on est dans ce contextel euh
le le CCS est la première réponse la
première réponse qu'on peut apporter à
des gens euh une fois de plus des gens
qui sont dans une situation inextricable
dans une situation où effectivement ce
sont des victimes et je tiens à le dire
parce qu'on ne le dit pas assez souvent
quand on est face à des marchands de
sommeil les habitants sont souvent des
victimes et ça a été dit et le CCS est
la première réponse alors certes nous
avons la particularité à mulouse de ne
pas avoir un CCS propriétaire de de
logement ou de bâtiment mais
effectivement c'est c'est vraiment une
réflexion qu'il faut avoir et vous
l'avez dit très justement monsieur nous
sommes peu élig au niveau du CS du du
CCAS un certain nombre d'aidees de
l'État ça aussi c'est une question qu'il
faut se poser et peut-être juste une
dernière remarque avant de céder la
parole à Alain Couchot une dernière
remarque on se rendcontre concernant les
administrateurs judicière alors la
particularité à mulouse par exemple
c'est qu'on a un seul cabinet qui traite
toutes ces questionsl et on se rend
compte qu'ils sont en train de
s'organiser en réseau enfin en tout cas
c'est la c'est le constat que je fais
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un un cabinet
prioritaire qui traite toutes ces
questionsl mais ils sont en connexion et
dans un réseau d'administrateurs
judiciaaires donc ça prouve aussi que
quelque part c'est peut-être une
nouvelle donne qu'il faut prendre en
compte la question de la la la capacité
ou de la formation de ces
administrateurs judiciaires qui sont
face à des problèmes récurrents et des
problèmes qui prennent de plus en plus
d'ampleur voilà j'ai essayé d'être
succinte et si vous permettez monsieur
le Premier Adjoint bien sûr merci Madame
la Président je voulais revenir sur la
question du numérique vous avez raison
monsieur le sénateur il faut d'abord de
l'humain et et Matthieu anottin l'a
rappelé il faut des moyens et c'est
quand on parle d'ingénierie il s'agit
bien sûr aussi de personnes qui ont la
capacité d'aller sur le terrain mais
autour de de de l'habitat indine gravite
un certain nombre d'organismes les
communes la DG FIP l'agence régionale de
santé la CAF chacun a son propre système
d'information et et très peu communique
je vais vous donner un exemple à M on a
mis en place le permis de louer on s'est
rendu compte assez rapidement que les
seules personnes qui demandaient le
permis de louer c'était les personnes de
bonne foi et qu'on avait pas la capacité
de savoir quelles étaient les personnes
qui ne le demandaient pas donc on a on a
mis un protocole d'accord avec la CAF
qui nous permet de savoir quels sont les
changements de bail et d'aller vérifier
que dans les cas dans ces changements il
y a bien un il y a bien un dépôt de
permis de Loué qui a été fait première
étape et et dernier 2è étape au bout de
la chaîne quand on a eu un certain
nombre de propriétaires en infraction et
qu'on a é misis des des titres d'amende
pour euh pour infraction on s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avit pas d'interconnexion
avec la DG FIP et ça a mis des mois pour
qu'on puisse pour qu'on puisse recouvrer
ces amendes évidemment la crédibilité du
système en prend un grand cût donc il
s'agit aussi d'avoir la capacité
d'interconnecter hein c'est le sens de
de la proposition les différents
systèmes d'information des acteurs qui
gravitent autour du du logement mais ça
n'enlève rien évidemment à la nécessité
d'avoir l'humain en premier plan merci
donc on va passer la parole à Dan Daniel
Fargeot Jean-Luc Brot et Bernard buis
Daniel merci madame la présidente madame
le Maire Monsieur le Maire alors
monsieur le Premier Adjoint répond d'ors
et déjà à la question que je souhaitais
parler mais je voulais revenir quand
même dessus sur ce permis de louer pour
moi le permis de louer c'est la solution
pour endiguer l'habitat indigne en règle
générale mais par ailleurs c'est une une
condition qui est très peu connu ou
voire méconnu euh voir peu mise en en
œuvre par les communes et autres PCI
c'est bien dommage parce
qu'effectivement ça permet d'identifier
au mieux les euh les propriétaires ou
les bailleurs indélicat sur nos communes
et vous parliez tout à l'heure de
pouvoir les identifier alors à la fois
par les CCS et c'est exactement ce que
j'ai fait sur ma commune mais aussi via
la DDFIP pour dénoncer un petit peu et
la Commission des impôts locaux puisque
bien souvent quand on fait appel à des
commissaires pour te pour gérer notre
notre commission des impôts locaux les
gens connaissent on les recessensent par
rapport à leur connaissance du terrain
depuis depuis fort longtemps donc je
crois que cette cette solution
d'endiguer effectivement par des mesures
cooheritives plus que pour améliorer
l'accompagnement et la protection des
habitants parce que c'est ce que vous
avez mis dans votre rapport j'ai je
viens de lire enfin j'ai lu durant notre
entretien que c'était la la proposition
21 moi je pense que c'est aussi une
possibilité de de de mesures
cooheritives quand même relativement
cohérentes et et importantes mais bien
évidemment il faut aussi assouplir les
conditions et favoriser les conditions
d'accès à ce permis de Loué via des
contrôles qui devrait être quand même
repris aussi par la puissance publique
être aidé par la puissance publique pour
favoriser la mise en œuvre des de ces
permis et puis de permis de loué et puis
aussi moi j'ai j'ai j'ai mis aussi au
sein de ma commune une sanction
financière pour notamment ses contrôles
pour refacturer au propriétaires un
délicat même après AG des contrôleurs à
l'euro l'euro le le coût de cette de
cette mission parce que sinon ça
représente encore une charge
supplémentaire pour nos collectivité
Jean-Luc
BR le micro Jean-Luc le
micro merci Madame la Président Monsieur
le Maire madame le Maire une question
dans les communes rurales aujourd'hui
qui se pose pour nous sur les logements
indignes et insalubres c'est aussi
maintenant ce qui nous est imposé pour
les CFI les gens du
voyage où là l'heure devient grave dans
une territoire comme le mien 7000
habitants 160 caravanes à l'année on
nous oblige maintenant à faire du
logement c'est que non seulement
aujourd'hui on règle pas les logements
indignes mais on nous oblige maintenant
à construire des logements pour les CFI
et comment vous voulez qu'on fasse on a
les logements digne et maintenant on a
160 caravanes chez nous à l'année qu'il
faut loger et il faut construire alors
je sais que c'est pas dans votre mission
c'est obligation hein c'est une
obligation non mais je sais bien que
c'est pas dans ce cadre là mais ce que
je voulais dire simplement dire c'est
que ne pas l'oublier ou l'évoquer parce
que je pense que vous Monsieur le Maire
de Saint- de de Saint-Denis vous devez
aussi avoir ces problèmes là
régulièrement merci présidente merci aux
auteurs de ce rapport très détaillé moi
je voudrais revenir sur trois choses la
première ça été évoquée par mon collègue
c'est le permis de louer qui a été mis
en place dans plus de 400 villes et qui
permet vraiment de mieux lutter contre
l'habitat indigne il permet de
travailler en amont en contrôlant les
logements avant toute mise en location
pensez-vous que l'on ne pourrait
pensez-vous que l'on pourrait
généraliser cette mise en place ma
deuxème question porte sur votre
proposition numéro 9 vous proposez la
création d'un syndicat à caractère
d'intérêt général comment
fonctionnerait-il en quoi serait-il
différent des syndicats actuels et enfin
pour terminer sur l'accompagnement des
victimes avec la création d'un fond de
garantie l'enjeu est aussi celui de
l'accompagnement et de la protection des
habitants à ce sujet vous imaginez dans
votre rapport la création d'un fond de
garantie pour les victimes indirectes le
temps des assurances étant parfois très
long il est important que dans le cas
d'un effondrement d'immeuble par exemple
une garantie puisse prendre le relais
avant que les assurances ne se charge du
dossier qui financerait ce fond et
quelles seraient les conditions pour le
déclencher je vous laisse la
parole sur ce dernier point très
clairement ce serait la sol la
solidarité nationale c'est l'état euh
enfin voilà sur la question du fond de
garantie sachant qu'on parle plutôt de
système
d'avance le temps que les assurances
prennent le relais plutôt que de voilà
de d'argent qui est qui est donné mais
en tout cas clairement pour moi c'est du
ressort de la solidarité nationale parce
que pour le coup euh c'est finalement
ces problèmes d'effondrement à l'échelle
du pays enfin on parle quand même de
quelques dizaines d'appartement aller
une centaine au maximum à l'échelle
d'une commune pour le coup ça peut
devenir insupportable
cette cette solidarité voilà ça peut
peser trop et à l'échelle du pays
honnêtement on on est vraiment sur les
enjeux financiers qui sont
microscopique à l'échelle du budget de
l'État peut-être moi je voulais laisser
la parole à Kathy Bontin ma première
adjointre sur le sujet parce que vous
étiez deux interrogés sur le permis de
louer fois pour vous dire nous où on en
est dans dans Histoire de mise en place
aussi et puis voilà des évolutions
auquell on a pensé de dans le
rapport merci Madame la président idente
Mesdames et Messieurs les les
commissaires sur le permis de louer nous
on a un recul maintenant de 4 ans
puisque l'intercommunalité pleine
commune a mis en place en
expérimentation déjà en 2019 et puis on
a réussi à généraliser aux neu villes du
du territoire donc on est vraiment avec
un panorama on avait expérimenté à la
fois l'autorisation préalable de mise en
location c'est-à-dire le permis de louer
le plus complet et puis la déclaration
préalable mais qui a moins bien
fonctionné donc on est vraiment à à à à
valoriser le système me vraiment de
l'autorisation préalable qui nécessite
de pouvoir derrière on revient à la
question de l'ingénierie puisque pour
qu'elle soit effective il faut renforcer
le le signalement on ne fait pas des
visites sur toutes les adresses mais la
cartographie qu'on a réussi à mettre en
place fait que on va faire les les les
visites et que derrière le montant de
travaux qui a pu être généré grâce aux
visites du permis de Loué commence à
être très significatif donc on est bien
sur un outil de prévention et
d'amélioration de de de de l'habitat la
la ce qu'on a nous voulu dans le rapport
à la fois posé c'est d'une part il y a
des aspects législatifs et
réglementaires d'aller quand même
vraiment plus loin pour que le décret
d'essence et le permis de loué soit
complètement en adéquation et qu'on
reparte pas non plus à chaque fois au
début de la procédure vous savez que les
CAF s'épuisent beaucoup puisque dès
qu'il y a un nouveau locataire
elles-même quand elles ont mis en place
des procédures et bien ça repart à zéro
puisque c'est lié à la demande d'APL
donc on a aussi toute une continuité
complètement à travailler avec avec les
CAF et puis dans le rapport ce qu'on a
dit tout à l'heure on dit que permis de
louer et permis de diviser doivent être
mis complètement complètement en
cohérence au-delà de ce qu'on a dit dans
le rapport nous sur un retour
d'expérience c'est comment rattraper les
propriétaires indélicats qui ne vont pas
demander le permis de louer puisque
finalement tous ceux qui jouent le jeu
ils demandent leur permis de louer dans
les temps ils attendent avant la mise en
location et souvent c'est on fait
quelques travaux d'amélioration de la
ventilation et cetera c'est bien mais
mais voilà et donc on a mis en place un
partenariat avec la CAF qui fait qu'il y
a un échange de données sur que toute
demande d'ouverture de droit à
laallocation personnalisée au logement
donne un retour pour pouvoir savoir s'il
n'y a pas eu une demande de de permis de
louer et ça c'est très efficace nous on
a plus de 100 signalements qui ont été
faits grâce à cette récupération de de
de données sur la cave donc c'est
complètement quelque chose à généraliser
qui est pas du ressort législatif
et qu'il faut pouvoir faire et puis
au-delà de ça on a croisé les données
avec enedis et avec volia puisque tout
ce qui est installation de compteur ou
surconsommation d'eau est un indicateur
très pertinent de repérage de la
suroccupation et du logement et du
Logement dortoire donc là on arrive
vraiment aussi à avoir quelque chose de
de très efficace et puis pour terminer
ça revient avec ce qui a été dit sur il
faut que les habitants puissent trouver
via un guichet unique physique en
complément du du numérique mais comment
aussi quand on va à domicile on a tout
de suite euh la petite lumière logement
indécent qui s'allume et donc les
infirmiers infirmières libérales qui
vont au domicile le SIAD le service de
portage de repas euh le la PMI et donc
on a formé à saintenis tous tous ces
travailleurs sociaux on va dire dans au
sens large qui vont venir faire un
pansement mais qui vont se dire là euh
on a une une situation particulière donc
souvent ces travailleurs déjà le
signalement de personnes vulnérables
mais parfois sur une sur des personnes
qui ne vont pas avoir besoin de
protection particulière elles vont pas
se dire je vais en plus rentrer et faire
un signalement comme quoi j'ai vu que le
le mur fissuré commencait commencer à
s'inquiéter et nous ça commence à
fonctionner à Saint-Denis la semaine
dernière on a on a évacué en urgence sur
un périliminant où on a même utilisé la
procédure d'urgence du 2212 pour sortir
en en quelques heures les personnes puis
qu'on était pas loin de la situation un
peu à à à Lille et donc on est bien sur
un un occupant qui avait repéré tout ce
qui était mis en place et qui a appelé
le service de de la ville parce que son
meuble de cuisine s'était décroché du
mur et il s'est juste dit que c'est
juste pas parce qu'il y avait une vis
qui était partie c'est que le mur était
en train de bouger en quelques heures et
donc on est on a on a sorti euh en
quelques heures les les les occupants
donc c'est vraiment toute cette chaîne
et on en revient aux moyens donnés
c'est-à-dire les moyens du CCAS du SCHS
dans les villes c'est pas dans le projet
de loi mais derrière les questions
financières d'accompagnement des
collectivités c'est ce qu'on attend du
plan d'action global lhi qui va bien
plus loin que ce projet de loi
merci Monsieur le Maire Mad le ouais
très rapidement si si vous me le
permettez
le le pardon euh sur sur permis douer
moi je veux dire c'est important qu'on
ait des outils enfin quand même 9
personnes sur 10 c'est des gens de bonne
volonté moi je veux surtout pas qu'on
pointe les petits propriétaires comme
étant tous des coupables et cetera et le
permis de louer il doit servir à les
accompagner y compris en leur donnant la
liste des choses à faire et ça marche
super bien de ce point de vuel et moi je
trouve que c'est un bon dispositif parce
que c'est un dispositif qui permet aussi
à des gens de pas parfois basculer
involontairement du mauvais côté de la
barrière en leur disant bah là vous avez
acheté vous êtes un peu
bordeur donc maintenant pour revenir
pleinement dans le droit bah il faut
faire si ça ça et cetera et nous on a
plein de solutions qui sont réservées
aussi comme ça et donc ça je pense que
je voulais le redire sur le syndicque
d'intérêt général j'ai un peu répondu
tout à l'heure mais peut-être pour vous
compreniez de manière plus spécifique
l'idée c'est d'essayer de mieux
spécifier les mission on a et c'est pour
ça qu'on on n'est pas aujourd'hui dans
le positionnement complètement prêt
qu'on voudrait expérimenter on a des
syndicques de redressement qui existent
ils font un travail et moi je ne le ni
pas et je dis pas qu'il faut dégommer
les syndicques les CQ de redressement
ils peuvent être extrêmement utiles mon
analyse c'est qu'ils sont utiles en fait
quand c'est pas quand on est dans une
situation où la copropriété est dégradée
mais que c'est pas trop tard et qu'on a
une copropriété qui veut agir et qui a
besoin d'être accompagné mais quand on a
une copropriété qui est défaillante euh
la collectivité elle a aussi besoin
d'une ingénierie privée à sa disposition
sinon en fait elle vient remplacer
l'ingénierie et donc et à la fin on
arrive toujours t pareil donc là on
pense qu'il faudrait un statut
finalement euh
spécifique parap public qui serait entre
la copropriété qui qui est redressable
avec un un bon niveau d'accompagnement
mais avec des gens volontaires et
l'administration judiciaire et le
traitement finalement 100 % 100 % public
voilà dans cette interstice et c'est
pour ça qu'on on voudrait expérimenter
ce syndique d'intérêt général madame le
Maire juste un mot pour pour compléter
ce que vient de dire Mathieu donc le le
syndique d'intérêt général ou publque
enfin tout dépend comment on peut on
peut l'appeler moi je pense que que ça
reste ça reste un un avant tout un
opérateur potentiel voilà euh je dis pas
que que ça doit systém qui doit
systématiquement entrer en ligne de
compte mais ça reste un des opérateurs
et je pense pouvoir dire que qu'au
niveau de la désignation par le tribunal
par exemple je pense qu'il sera plus
simple de d'interpeller et de missionner
un syndique d'intérêt général que de
missionner peut-être des un syndique
privé ou apparenté privé parce qu'on
sait aussi et je l'ai dit dans dans ma
présentation on voit qu'il y a des
syndiques de qualités différentes et
d'interventions différentes voilà et
donc quelque part il faut aussi des
garants dans l'intervention du syndicque
en terme de je dirais du formation des
gens qui constituent le syndicque et en
terme de de qualité comme opérateur
potentiel alors Mathieu l'a dit je pense
que là où il a un rôle très très
important c'est au niveau curatif quand
on quand il y a l'établissement d'un
plan très en amont sur le ce plan
curatif à mon avis ne peut-être gérer
que peur à un syndique d'intérêt public
parce que il y a trop d'ux financier ça
a été dit voilà alors Anne Catherine
Loisier Sophie prima Marianne Margaté
merci Madame et Monsieur le Maire pour
pour ce travail de d'analyse et de
synthèse et et de recommandation euh je
je je pense que on a tous bien identifié
les les points clés relatifs à à la
gouvernance et à à l'ingénieurerie sur
les territoires mais vous venez de
d'évoquer cette question c'est quel
financement voilà comment les choses
peuvent être réellement mises en place
sur le territoire sur les territoires
moi je voudrais revenir sur un point qui
a je crois pas encore été évoqué c'est
votre proposition 22 euh qui vise à à à
doter la police municipale de pouvoir
d'enquête judiciaire ça c'est un sujet
important pour les maires hein les
pouvoirs d'enquête judiciaire de la
police municipale
euh alors est-ce moi je pense que c'est
absolument fondamental et mais comment
vous voyez la faisabilité parce que moi
il me semblait que quand on on rentrait
sur ce champ en fait c'est c'est c'est
le procureur normalement du coup qui qui
prend la main euh voilà donc comment
est-ce que vous voyez à ce moment-là le
le partenariat entre élu et et et
procureur sur ces sujets merci toophie
prima merci madame la Présidente merci à
vous madame le Maire Monsieur le Maire
et vos équipes d'avoir travaillé sur ce
sujet qui est un sujet qui nous
préoccupe avec la présidente
estrosissasone depuis depuis
longtemps et merci de de d'orienter
votre rapport et donc le projet de loi
sur le pouvoir d'agir des Maes parce
qu'il s'agit bien il s'agit bien de ça
en fait moi j'ai des questions sur le
l'équilibre avec le le droit de
propriété parce que j'ai bien compris
que dans vos propositions à juste titre
il y avait des des mesures qui allaient
dans le sens d'une d'une expropriation
et une prise de propriété par la par le
pouvoir public quel qu'il soit plus
rapide comment est-ce que vous avez
essayé de d'assurer l'équilibre avec le
droit de propriété qui va être
évidemment évoqué je pense lors de cette
ce projet de loi euh bien évidemment il
faut que les propriétaires qui ne sont
pas tous des malfaisants vous avez
raison madame le Maire puisse faire des
des recours et du coup c'est ces recours
qui souvent nous prennent beaucoup de
temps dans les procédure enfin il y a
pas que ça mais ça aussi est-ce que vous
traitez cette histoire de de recours
dans dans vos propositions et dans le de
dans le projet de loi 3è question sur le
droit de propriété euh avec madame la
Présidente nous sommes allés pour le
coup en outreemire ou la question je
vois que la présidente de la délégation
est pas là donc je me permets ou la
question du propriétaire même se pose
aujourd'hui euh est-ce que vous avez
là-dessus fait des propositions
particulières euh et puis une dernière
remarque mais qui est plus générale j'ai
bien entendu votre recommandation qui me
paraît bon sens de bon sens de faire des
contrôles de de structure des bâtiments
en souriant un peu je dirais que c'est
une norme supplémentaire que que nous
que que nous nous apprêtons donc à à
mettre nous qui sommes toujours
réticents à mettre des normes
supplémentaires euh assurons nous
qu'elle soit bien coordonné avec les DPE
parce que avec toutes les autres les
autres diagnostics c'est pas les mêmes
les mêmes compétences donc ça va
demander des compétences supplémentaires
des cabinets supplémentaires des frais
supplémentaires qui les prend en charge
comment on l'organise comment on le
refait au bout de 10 ans au bout de 15
ans enfin bon il faut être attentif à ça
parce que vous savez que vous êtes élu
locaux donc les normes souvent nous
cassent les
pieds mais je comprends le sens ça voilà
merci Sophie Marianne
Margaté merci madame la Présidente merci
pour pour cette mission et cet échange
sur ce sujet vous l'avez dit d'ampleur
et de gravité donc l'intervention une
intervention publique forte et en effet
indispensable mais elle s'inscrit quand
même dans un cadre qui va la rendre
encore plus difficile on l'a vu sur la
mission logement cohésion des
territoires avec la crise des logement à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés
évidemment qui va ne faire je dirais
qu'accélérer
qu'aggraver c'estes pr enfin l'habitat
indine les C pour dégradé puisque ça
n'offre plus de possibilités ni de
sortie et et on sait très bien que les
personnes victimes de marchands de
sommeil sont celles qui sont souvent en
marge hors de droit commun et qui hélas
non plus que ce refuge le terme est très
mauvais puisque ça en est pas un
puisqu'elles sont victimes d'un habitat
extrêmement
euh enfin insupportable à vivre mais on
s'inscrit aussi dans ce contexte là qui
qui n'est pas de enfin voilà qui va être
difficile pour donner des perspectives
de long terme également sur la question
de l'interdiction de louer des logements
en étiquette FG d'ici à 2028 qui
pourrait accélérer ce processus ce
phénomène descopropriétés dégradé et
s'il n'y a pas de réinvestissement par
les propriétaires bailleurs le risque et
de voir augmenter sur le marché le
nombre de de logements à la vente qui
est bien réel et qui pourrait être une
auè supplémentaire pour des
propriétaires peu respectueux de de des
règles donc on est dans ce contexte là
et je voulais le le le préciser sur la
question moi je partage l'idée de
proximité pour être plus
efficace mais également la difficulté
des communes et ça a été évoqué par
Madame à un moment donné sur des moyens
financiers qui sont enfin il faut faire
des choix soluble à un moment donné
parce que
supporter que la commune ou
l'intercommunalité lorsqu'il s'agit de
petite communes doivent embaucher là des
inspecteurs de salubrité sur lequel on a
un problème de recrutement il y a un
problème de formation on se fait enfin
toutes les communes se font concurren
pour essayer de trouver des inspecteurs
de salalibrité qu'on ne trouve pas avec
en plus une articulation avec le préfet
et l'ARS qui est parfois compliqué qui
doit y aller comment les les compétences
de chacun comment on eff cas et je sais
pas si d'ailleurs au niveau de de la
place de la RS de ces moyens dans dans
le dans votre mission vous avez pu
l'étudier donc je pense qu'on a vraiment
lorsqu'on affaibli le service public
local on l'affaiblit également sur ce
sujet là qui est la détection
l'intervention de nos agents pour pour
accompagner en effet les victimes et
c'est très important et pour engager un
processus de mettre fin à à à cet
habitat indigne moi je suis beaucoup
plus partagé sur le fait de leur donner
en plus des compétences de police
judiciaire je pense qu'à un moment donné
l'articulation de chacun des acteurs
est est une bonne chose plutôt que de
multiplier les chargees qui pèse sur euh
sur nos agents mer merci je vous laisse
répondre madame le Maire Monsieur le
Maire oui juste rapidement mais je
laisserai Mathieu continuer sur la
question de l'expropriation euh la
question effectivement de donner des des
des pouvoirs supplémentaires à la police
municipale euh effectivement se se pose
la question et j'avais eu l'occasion
d'échanger avec monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur assez récemment il y a à peu
près un mois sur cette questionlà
puisqu'il souhaitait donner des pouvoirs
supplémentaires aux policiers municipaux
faut-il le faire de cette manière- làà
et vous l'avez dit très justement madame
nous nous sommes face une fois de plus à
à des moyens RH que nous n'avons pas
clairement donc comment est-ce qu'on
résout ces moyens RH est-ce qu'il faut
faut former certains policiers
municipaux sans doute pas tous mais
certains policiers municipaux qui
seraient affectés à d'autres mission
c'est la question mais comme dit avec
toute l'humilité dont on peut faire
preuve je pose la question les les
inspecteurs de salubrité sur un
territoire comme le nôtre nous en avons
un seul pour deux départements et que
nous n'arrivons pas à sollicité éidment
donc un moment donné se pose la question
et et je reviens à ce qui a été dit tout
à l'heure plus plus nous serons réactifs
plus vite nous aurons des enquêtes
administratives et judiciaire plus vite
nous pourrons agir si nous n'avons pas
ce déclencheur nous ne pouvons pas agir
bien évidemment et je suis d'accord avec
vous Madame ça ne peut pas se faire
autrement qu'ou se légide de du
procureur de la République bien sûr
c'est un préalable et c'est ce que c'est
ce que c'est ce qu'avait annoncé
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur ça ne pourra se faire que
sous l'égide du procureur voilà mais en
même temps ça ne peut pas non plus être
le juge de l'expropriation par exemple
qui peut remplir ce genre de mission
donc voilà on est on est vraiment dans
dans cette espèce de de de de circuit
infernal où si on narrive pas à
déclencher une enquête donc on ne peut
pas saisir la justice et donc nous ne
pouvons pas réagir et effectivement si
nous l'avons noté dans notre rapport par
c'est bien aussi parce que c'est un
souci au quotidien un souci auquel
effectivement nous n'avons pas de
réponse sur la question du contrôle de
structure effectivement en général il y
a un plan pluriannuel de travaux et nous
avions imaginé pouvoir inscrire cette
obligation de de contrôle de
structure dans ce à l'intérieur de ce
plan pluriannuel de travaux voilà
effectivement si on commence
à à fragmenter les choses et avoir de
plus en plus de diagnostic à réaliser et
on imaginait bien quand on a préparé ce
rapport avec Mathieu ça ça pourrait être
par exemple un diagnostic à réaliser par
exemple tous les 10 ans on sait très
bien que ça ne peut pas être réalisé de
la même manière que d'autres
diagnostique voilà mais c'est une
proposition une fois de plus mais on
aimerait bien l'intégrer dans ce stade à
ce stade là je laisse ma ouis sur le
débat des des polices
municipales moi moi j'ai un avis très
arrêté sur la question c'est un avis
très positif dans le sens où il faut que
l'on puisse
participer pas faire à la place de mais
sur le sujet de l'habit indigne en fait
on a un problème de moyen humain
existant globalement et ces problèmes de
moyen maain ils sont vrais dans la
police nationale ils sont vrais dans la
justice aussi et donc je pense qu'il
faut pas comment dire il faut utiliser
toutes les ressources qu'on a
aujourd'hui on a des policiers
municipaux des inspecteurs de salubrité
qui vont faire un travail qui va être un
travail qui ressour du
constat il font des PV mais ils vont pas
plus loin ils peuvent pas y compris
déclencher ils doivent parfois attendre
que il y ait la brigade spécialisée du
département qui puisse venir pour faire
ça parfois du coup tout la sorte de
préenquête qu' ont fait seetrouve tombé
à l'eau parce que le propriétaire sent
qu'il se passe un truc et donc il
expulse les locataires et puis bah
derrière pourut repartir à zéro donc
donc voilà
donc ça c'est mon avis moi je pense
qu'il faut et c'est ce que j'ai dit au
minist de l'Intérieur surt les pouvoirs
de police du maire je pense qu'il faut
qu'on le traite y compris dans une
dimension contractuelle entre la
collectivité et l'État pour pas qu'on
oblige une collectivité à activer tel
ressort ou tel ressort si elle le
souhaite ou si elle ne souhaite pas
parce que les réalités sont différentes
d'un endroit à l'autre du territoire
mais demain honnêtement enfin je on a
donné des capacités d'enquête des
pouvoirs d'enquête aux inspecteurs de
l'environnement enfin je veux dire c'est
c'est pourquoi il sont pas des
inspecteurs de salubrité ils sont là il
y en a pas assez c'est vrai en faudrait
plus c'est vrai mais pour ceux qui sont
là autant les utiliser enfin je au
maximum de de ce qu'on peut faire enfin
je c'est moi c'est cette un peu
dichichotomie de c'est des pouvoirs
judiciaaires donc forcément c'est l'état
ENF honnêtement je trouve que c'est
enfin ce jacobinisme complet il il est
pas cohérent par rapport à la réalité de
ce qu'on
vit sur le terrain euh et pour le coup
il y a un projet de loi qui quand même
sur les PM semble être dans le circuit
si je peux m'exprimer ainsi et qui
pourrait être l'occasion d'avoir aussi
ce débat là vous m'avez interrogé sur la
question des gardesfous sur droit de
propriété on a essayé de faire justement
quelque chose de très
équilibré oui il y a des il y a quand on
élargit le droit à l'expropriation je
vais pas vous dire que à un moment donné
onélargit pas c'est vrai on crée un
nouveau droit à l'expropriation mais qui
est borné et en tout cas c'est notre
souhait euh il faut pour qu'on puisse
exercer ce nouveau droit d'préation que
votre immeuble
euh il soit frappé d'arrêter de péril
euh ou d'incalubrité et il faut que
votre immeuble soit frappé d'arrêter de
péril inalubrité et que une liste de
prescriptions qui sont faites ne soit
pas
respecté il y a une double condition et
on va euh je sais plus si le j'ai pas lu
le détail du projet de loi enfin nous on
pensait que c'était grosso modo fallait
c'est un an 2 ans enfin un temps quand
même au copropriétaire pour s'organiser
et c'est toujours pareil si en fait ce
qu'il faut bien voir c'est que il faut
laisser derrière toute façon il y aura
un contrôle judiciaire il y aura des
voies de recours sur ces procédures et
donc si un maire utilise abusivement de
ce droit mais un arrêté de péril alors
qu'il a pas lieu de le mettre et ce il
se mettra en faute et là il sera pour le
coup voilà il compris du coup vous avez
raccourci délais de recours ou pas alors
les délais de recours les délais de
recours le problème c'est que on n'est
pas sur du traitement enfin là
typiquement moi je faut évidemment des
raccourciis aujourd'hui ce qui fait que
les d recours sont longs c'est les
traitements c'est le temps de traitement
judiciaire essentiellement donc oui on a
mis par exemple dans not proposition
qu'il y a un juge de l'expropriation
dans chacun des tribunaux oui on a mis
dans une proposition le fait qu'il ait
un parquet dédié à la lutte contre
l'habitat indigne dans chacun des
départements et c'est et du coup la
chaîne judiciaire qui va avec qui est
aussi l'ingénierie pénale pour le coup
mais qui sont aussi pour le coup des
moyens pour la justice sur cette
question des moyens pourquoi est-ce que
on on en a pas plus parler que ça moi je
vous dis honnêtement si on veut gagner
la bataille de l'habitat indigne oui ça
se demandera aussi un investissement
financier de la puissance publique
pendant les 10 à 15 ans qui viennent on
se trompe pas et il va falloir que ça
monte en puissance c'est vrai mais
comprenez-moi moi je voulais pas que le
point de départ de ce qu'on fait c'est
dit faut de l'argent faut de l'argent
faut de l'argent faut de l'argent et
tant qu'on a pas de l'argent en fait on
peut rien faire voilà donc nous le
constat qu'on fait c'est que à droit
constant on a un problème et donc on dit
commençons déjà par changer un certain
nombre de règles qui aujourd'hui sont
incohérentes peuvent nous permettre déjà
d'accélérer et effectivement le débat du
budgétaire de toute façon on doit
l'avoir tous les ans a prori si mes
souvenirs de parlementaires sont bons et
donc dépend où
çap non mais
mais vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est le débat de l'argent en
fait c'est un débat qui est un débat
récurrent qui sera un débat permanent et
moi moi si vous demande la conviction
oui il faudrait que je pense que demain
on mon avis j'avais fait une proposition
quand j'éis parlementaire en ce sens
c'est qu'on on puisse créer une taxe
affectée sur quelque chose qui alimente
précisément la lutte contre l'habitat
indigne euh et moi je pense que y
compris les Français quand on leur dit
on vous prend de l'argent mais c'est
pour faire ça ils comprennent mieux que
quand c'est pour être euh dilué euh
j'avais proposé à l'époque mais c'était
mon côté un peu gauchiste vous le
reconnaîtrez bien volontiers de faire
une taxation sur l'immobilier de luxe en
créant un DMTO complémentaire pour les
appartements qui se vendaient plus d'un
million d'euros personne n'est
parfaitou et c'est quoi le luxe plus d'
qui se vendait plus d'un million d'euros
et on rajoutait à chaque million on
rajoutait 1 % de DMTO donc cel quis ont
des 10 millions il rajoué 10 points 10
points de DMTO voilà ce qui touchait
assez peu les Français mais voilà bref
ce n'est pas à l'ordre du jour alors il
n rest les archives il nous reste deux
dernières questions Annique jacquem et
Franck
montoger merci Madame la prés Présidente
je vous remercie aussi comme mes
collègues pour la la qualité de votre
rapport moi je voudrais aborder
euh le point des délais vous venez
vaguement de d'en parler est-ce que vous
avez imaginé une procédure idéale ou un
schéma idéal entre l'identification du
bien les obligations diagnostiques vous
en avez parlé complet ou structurel le
temps de justice de rétrocession d'ex
d'expropriation d'administrateur
judiciire on connaît tous cette
problématique dans nos territoirees
aussi bien pour l'urbain que pour le
rural et avez-vous pu estimer un temps
incompressible de gestion de ces
dossiers puisque vous avez parlé de 23
ans pour le premier dossier que vous
avez eu à à traiter en nous disant bien
que maintenant vous sauez mieux faire ou
dans un temps plus court voilà est-ce
que vous pouvez nous donner finalement
une échelle de temps si c'est possible
euh si tout roule et euh deuxème
question comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
justement borner dans le temps est-ce
qu'il y a moyen de mettre des
obligations des délais maximaux de
traitement ou de réponsse à ces dossiers
parce que je pense que pour ceux qui
s'en occupent ces sources et d'agacement
et de découragement quand on voit que ça
traîne sur sur des années et la deuxième
question madame la mère vous l'avez
abordé le plan pluriannuel des travaux
moi j'ai je suis en ce moment un dossier
dans le département du dou dans une
petite commune aussi de d'habitant
insalubre avec une obligation de de
faire réaliser des travaux d'office qui
relèvent donc de de l'urgence et euh on
a fait une une réunion à la mairie et la
représentante de la DDT nous a bien dit
bah vous savez cette commune là vu sa
taille ne va pas être prioritaire donc
les travaux vont pas être engagés avant
un an un an et demi parce que justement
au niveau proportion par rapport au
reste de l'habitat voilà alors est-ce
que là encore on parlait c'est Amel qui
en parlait tout à l'heure comment est-ce
qu'on différencie finalement le
traitement des dossiers de l'urbain et
du rural merci Fran Montauger rapidement
et Stéphane foissin merci madame la
Présidente merci à à vous pour ce
travail de fond très très intéressant je
j'aurais une question toute simple mais
je je pense qu'elle est assez compliquée
euh en même temps pour y répondre est-ce
que vous avez une une estimation globale
ou par dispositif proposé des coûts des
coûts de votre plan
d'action voilà alors Stéphane Passin on
par en autre mère oui très rapidement
c'est sur Oui sur les les EPF vous savez
que les communes les petites communes
n'ont pas forcément les moyens de faire
l'acquisition immédiatement des des des
immeubles ou des propriétés et font
souvent demande à le PF de faire un
portage sur 5 ou 7 ans et on récupère le
bâtiment dans un état désastreux alors
qu'il pourrait être misise à disposition
immédiatement aux communes dès
l'acquisition par le PF ce qui est pas
le cas à la Réunion je sais pas comment
ça fonctionne dans les autres EPF mais
on se retrouve effectivement avec des
bâtiments complètement délabrés euh
après le temps de portage le temps
d'acquisition comment accélérer cela ou
mettre en place une solution pour que
les mairies puissent être propriétaire
immédiatement je vous laisse répondre
bon sur sur le sur le foncier en fait
chaque EPF est un peu maître aussi de sa
politique nous il nous mettent plutôt
une borne à 50 de portage maximumy ce
que dire c'est que c'est avec un
objectif que justement ils veulent
acheter des biens que des biens dans
lesquels on a un proj d'activation à 5
ans donc quasi immédiat en je ve dire
pour enfin en tout cas que le projet est
posé moi mon sujet c'est plutôt comment
est-ce qu'on arrive à construire des
portages longs sur du 10 ans sur du 15
ans sur du 20 ans pour faire de la
ressource foncière pour faire de
l'anticipation sur sur sur sur nos
collectivités la difficulté quand on
parle d'habitat indignne pas parler de
la question foncière en général ça va
trop élargir le scope c'est c'est que
c'est la question du grignotage c'est
que souvent on a des multi propriétés et
donc il faut qu'on aille prendre un
morceau un bout et donc ça ça prend
aussi du temps et c'est de l'argent qui
est immobilisé et je préfère que soit
l'argent concrètement des des
des outils fonciers qui sont faits pour
ça plutôt que notre argent des communes
qui doit être actif et qui doit servir
justement à faire des projets à dépenser
pour construire des projets
d'aménagement pas pour être stocké dans
les acquisitions foncières sinon on este
façon de toute façon très vite
limité le le coût du rapport ben c'est
simple c'est exactement pour ça qu'on n'
pas voulu faire un rapport qui coûtait
de l'argent en fait c'est ce rapport
qu'on a fait c'est pas un rapport de
dépenses c'est un rapport qui change les
règles donc c'est un rapport qui permet
d'agir plus vite plus fort et
accessoirement moins cher parce que ce
qui est vrai c'est que ce qui coûte le
plus cher dans tout ce qu'on raconte
c'est aujourd'hui quand on intervient
tout au bout de la chaîne
donc fait plus on intervient en amont
moins on dépense d'argent soit les soit
la puissance publique soit d'ailleurs
les acteurs soit les acteurs privés la
question des délais pour essayer de vous
répondre aussi bien que possible
euh c'est c'est elle est elle est très
complexe parce que on est sur des
réalités qui sont effectivement
radicalement différentes forcément d'un
bien à
l'autre il y a quand même dans l'idée de
dire si on rend force les
pouvoirs du maire c'est
aussi vous savez le maire il préférrea
toujours traiter à laamable parce que ça
ira toujours plus vite à l'amable que
dans le cas d'une procédure
d'expropriation judiciaire parce qu'au
moins laamable il y a pas de recours
c'est réglé c'est signé et on en parle
plus mais plus le maire il a aussi des
pouvoirs d'agir de contrainte plus ça
facilite le règlement des dossiers à
l'amable il faudrait qu'on arrive sur
des traitements d'immeubl d'habitant
indigne qu'on ait des délais de
traitement global qui n'excèdent pas
enfin qui sont entre 5 et 10 ans c'est
ça l'objectif euh il y a un temps
d'expropriation qui devrait être il y a
un temps de d'abord d'identification il
doit y avoir un temps de recours de de
tentativ pour les copropriétaires de
prendre en main leur destin par
eux-mêmes et après il y a le temps de
constat euh de l'inefficacité do avoir
un temps du coup
d'expropriation qui devrait pas excéder
2 ans quand même pour faire des
expropriations à partir moment où on
silence un temps de recours 2 ans de
plus voilà et tout ça nous mais voyez on
est sur du quand on identifie un
problème depuis les premiers arê de
péril 7 ans alors peut-être que des fois
sera 6 des fois sera 8 mais je pense que
c'est en tout cas cette échelle de temps
là qu'on essaie de viser avec nos
propositions et pas sur du 20 25 anss
madame le Maire vous voulez conclure euh
bien volontiers oui oui parce que je je
crois que c'est déjà l'heure de la
conclusion juste rapidement pour
répondre à Madame quand il y a un plan
pluriannuel de travaux c'est que la
copropriété ne fonctionne déjà pas si
mal que ça voilà déjà ça c'est un
préalable quant au financement parce
qu'on a parlé beaucoup financement là on
reparle de nouveau de la solidarité
nationale et c'est là pour ça on parlait
j'ai parlé de grandes causes nationales
dans ces cas-là on pourrait solliciter
la solidarité nationale et ça veut dire
aussi on a bien sûr échangé aussi avec
d'autres acteurs que sont Lana que sont
la banque des territoires là aussi des
acteurs à solliciter et comment est-ce
qu'on peut les
solliciter donc pour terminer juste
rapidement moi je tenais vraiment à vous
remercier madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs pour l'ensemble des
questions et je crois que voilà
vousassci pardon je m'associe pleinement
remerci tu t'associe Mathieu donc je
parle pour Mathieu àtin et pour moi-même
merci de nous avoir écouté de nous avoir
entendu et je suis sûre que c'est le cas
et comme je me suis permise de le dire
quand nous avions un échange
téléphonique avec madame la Présidente
bien évidemment mesdames et messieurs
nous comptons beaucoup sur vous puisque
vous êtes maintenant nos planches de
salut dans la suite du dispositif si je
peux m'exprimer ainsi et je tenais
vraiment à vous remercier pour ce moment
d'échange qui pour moi a été vraiment
révélateur et en même temps très
structurant et qui nous engage à
continuer dans nos réflexions merci à
vous merci vraiment au nom de toute la
commission et de l'ensemble des
commissaires
voilà le 25 janvier à sainti pour ceux
qui veulent les applaudissements
témoignent en tout cas de la qualité des
travaux de vos interventions des
réponses que vous avez apporté à des
questions extrêmement nombreuses de tous
les commissaires donc bien évidemment
vous avez compris combien la commission
des affaires économiques plus
particulièrement est mobilisée et depuis
un certain nombre d'années avec la
présidente prima et aujourd'hui moi-même
sur ces sujetslà mais c'est largement
partagé sur tous les bande de
l'hémicycle et nous serons au
rendez-vous n'en doutez pas donc on va
voir arriver ce projet de loi d'abord à
l'Assemblée nationale le 22 janvier et
ensuite quand il arrivera ici au Sénat
et bien évidemment ben entre-temps la
personne qui aura été le commissaire qui
aura été nommé rapporteur maintiendra un
certain nombre fera un certain nombre
d'dition nous aurons effectivement ce
déplacement sur le terrain Monsieur le
Maire chez vous le 25 janvier qui sera
aussi source de de de réflexion et de
concrétisation directement sur ce que
vous avez déjà fait ce que vous
continuez à faire et comment aussi
aujourd'hui on peut à la fois simplifier
et accélérer merci et puis bien
évidemment on reste aussi à votre
disposition au fur à mesure de la
discussion parlementaire n'hésitez pas
aussi l'un comme l'autre à revenir vers
vous avec vos élus et vos services voilà
bonne continuation à vous merci Madame
si les commissaires peuvent